GOOD AFTERNOON.
LIKE OPEN THE MEETING TODAY AND
I WANT TO THANK EVERYONE FOR
BEING HERE TODAY.
AND FOR ALL THE INPUT WE RECEIVE
FROM THE PUBLIC.
IN OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I'D LIKE TO THANK --
STAFF WERE ALLOWED THE
SIGNIFICANT WORK FIT IN ALL OF
US.
FOR AND OUTLINED OF TERMS THAT
WE WILL DISCUSS TODAY.
AS I'VE SAID WE MUST STAND BY
THE VICTIMS PREVENT FTURE FIRES
FROM CLAIMING NEW VICTIMS WE
MUST PROTECT THE LONG TERM
INTEREST OF EVERY UTILITY RATE
PAYER.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WE CAN ALL AGREE THAT THE STATUS
QUO IS UNACCEPTABLE.
AND WE HAVE A REAL OPPORTUNITY
MAKE REAL PROGRESS TO THOSE TO
THOSE GOALS.
I WILL READ THROUGH THE OUTLINED
THAT TURNED OVER TO MY CO CHAIR.
IN THEN OF TO THE REST OF THE
COMMITTEE.
WE WILL THEN OPEN IT TO PUBLIC
COMMENT.
I WANT TO POINT OUT THAT THIS
OUTLYING CONSTITUTES
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM COMMITTEE
STAFF AND IT'S BEEN VETTED BY
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE.
THE OUTLYING WILL BE POSTED
ONLINE THIS AFTERNOON AND WE
WELCOME ADDITIONAL INPUT ONLINE.
I BELIEVE THERE ARE COPIES THEY
OUTLINED --
ON THE TABLE HERE --
ANYMORE MAKING MORE COPIES SO
EVERYONE HAS.
ONE NOW LET'S --
REVIEWS THE OUTLINE OF THE THE
KEY ELEMENTS OF THE CONFERENCE
REPORT PLANNING.
THIS ELEMENT OF THE CONFERENCE
REPORT WILL HAVE NEW
REQUIREMENTS FOR BOTH IOUS MP
ó USE. TO PREPARE ADOPT AND
IMPLEMENT COMPREHENSIVE FIRE
[inaudible]
PREVENTION CLIENTS.
LANGUAGE AND CONTENT SUPPLANTS
WILL LARGELY TRACK THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL THAT HAS
BEEN PUBLIC IT ONLINE FOR
SEVERAL WEEKS.
AND THAT WAS REVIEWED IN PUBLIC
HEARING IN A PUBLIC HEARING TWO
WEEKS AGO.
IN ADDITION TO THE CPU SEE THE I
OWE YOU PLANS WILL BE REVIEWED
BY CAL FIRE AND OTHER STATE
EXPERTS. TO ENSURE PLANS IN
MEASURES ARE LEADING EDGE
REQUIREMENTS PREVENT WILDFIRES.
P. -- YOU
PLANTS WILL BE SUBJECT TO REVIEW
AND IMPLEMENTATION BY LOCAL P.
O. YOU GOVERNING BODIES.
FORESTRY AND LANDSCAPE
MANAGEMENT.
THE SEGMENT OF THE CONFERENCE
REPORT ALONG WITH PENDING
LEGISLATION WILL CONTAIN
COMPREHENSIVE STREAMLINING OF
LANDSCAPING FOR ST MANAGEMENT.
IT WILL CONTAIN SMALL LANDOWNER
INCENTIVES FUEL REDUCTION AND
OTHER MEASURES TO EXPEDITE
REMOVAL OF DEAD AND DYING TREES
IN CHAPARRAL FROM MODERATE
SIGNIFICANT.
IN EXTREME FIRE RISK AREAS.
THESE PROVISIONS WILL ALSO
INCLUDE SEQUEL STREAMLINING
SMALL LANDOWNER EXEMPTIONS FROM
TIMBER HARVESTING PLAN RULES IN
NEW REQUIREMENTS FOR THE STATE
AIR RESOURCES BOARD. TO QUANTIFY
IN PUBLISHED GREENHOUSE GAS
LIMIT EMISSIONS FROM FIRES.
THIS ALSO THIS ELEMENT ALSO WILL
EXTEND SOME EXISTING BIOMASS
CONTRACTS IN REVISED STANDARDS
THE PLANTS MUST MEET IN ORDER TO
GIVE MORE FLEXIBILITY ON MONTHLY
AND ANNUAL REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS.
THESE PROVISIONS WILL ALSO
REQUIRE ALL CONSERVATION
EASEMENTS GRANTED BY STATE
AGENCIES TO INCLUDE CONDITIONS
FOR A WILDFIRE.
FUELS REDUCTION CARBON
SEQUESTRATION AND WHILE THAT
WILDLIFE HABITAT DETECTION.
CP YOU SEE REASON THE
REASONABLENESS REVIEW THIS
SEGMENT OF THE CONFERENCE REPORT
WILL REVISE AND ADD NEW
PROVISIONS TO CURRENT LAW.
DIRECTING THE CPUC TO TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT ADDITIONAL FACTORS SUCH
AS THE NAY NATURE AND SEVERITY
OF THE CONDUCT OF THE OF THE I
OWE YOU.
WHETHER IT THIS WEEK DISREGARDED
RISK OF FIRES WEATHER FACTORS
OUTSIDE THE CONTROL OF THE I OR
YOU WERE A CAUSAL FACTOR IT.
IN THE FIRE WHETHER IT HAD A
PAST RECORD OF DISREGARD FOR
FIRE PROTECTION AND WHETHER
EXTREME WEATHER EVENTS.
CONTRIBUTED TO THE FIRE.
I OWE YOU RATE PAYER PROTECTION
BONDS.
THIS SEGMENT OF THE CONFERENCE
REPORT WILL ALLOW CPUC TO
AUTHORIZE AND I OWE YOU TO
FINANCE THOSE BECAUSE THEY'RE
PUTTING UTILITY RATES WHERE THEY
ARE A RESULT OF A CATASTROPHIC
FIRE.
FINANCING THE SCOTS WITH
APPROPRIATE PARAMETERS IS A
MECHANISM FOR THE CPU SEEM TO
APPROVE A DEDICATED RATE
COMPONENT. TO ALLOW AND I ó
YOU TO SELL REVENUE BONDS TO
HELP PAY OFF THAT DEBT INTO
MANAGING EVEN OUT COSTS TO
RATEPAYERS TO AVOID STE RATE
SPIKES IN EXCESSIVE UTILITY
BILLS [inaudible]
MUTUAL AID.
THIS SEGMENT OF THE CONFERENCE
REPORT WILL EXPAND THE PURPOSES
OF THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
BUDGET ACT APPROPRIATION FOR
MUTUAL AID.
SO THEY CAN BE USED MORE
EXPANSIVELY TO PRE POSITION
FIGHTERS AND EQUIPMENT WORKING
WITH LOCAL RESPONDERS --
TO INTERDICT IT A GUY
[inaudible]
FIRES EARLY --
TO PREVENT MORE SEVERE DAMAGE.
I DO YOU EXECUTIVE COMPENSATION.
THIS ELEMENT OF THE CONFERENCE
REPORT WILL PROHIBIT ANY
EXPENDITURES OF UTILITY REPAIR
FUNDS TO PAY FOR I OWE YOU
EXECUTIVE COMPENSATION OR PERKS
[inaudible]
JOB I IN WORKER PROTECTIONS THIS
ELEMENT OF THE CONFERENCE REPORT
WILL CONTAIN JOB PROTECTIONS FOR
PUBLIC FIREFIGHTERS AND WILL
PROTECT I OWE YOU WORKERS.
IN THE UNLIKELY EVENT ABOUT IT
AND I OWE YOU INSOLVENCY.
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT FOR
FORESTRY FIRE IN CARBON
REDUCTION ACTIVITIES.
THIS SEGMENT OF THE CONFERENCE
REPORT WILL EXTEND CURRENT ONE
TIME BUDGET YOUR FUNDING FROM
GREENHOUSE GAS.
FROM THE V. GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND OVER MULTIPLE
YEARS TO ENSURE CONSISTENT AND
SUSTAINED INVESTMENT IN FORCE
MANAGEMENT.
HEALTHY FOREST IN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S FORCE CARBON
REDUCTION PLAN.
BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION THIS
ELEMENT OF THE CONFERENCE REPORT
WILL ESTABLISH A BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSION TO EXAMINE AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
LEGISLATURE.
AND GOVERNOR ON MORE EFFECTIVE
WAYS TO SOCIALIZE THE COST OF
DAMAGES FROM WILDFIRES AND
WHETHER TO SET UP A FUND. TO
ASSIST IN THE PAYMENT OF COST.
THE COMMISSION WOULD REPORT BACK
IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN WITH
ITS RECOMMENDATIONS.
THIS POINT I WILL CALL ON CODE
HOLDEN TO FOR HIS REMARKS.
THANK YOU --
A CULTURE DODD.
MY REMARKS WILL BE A LOT SHORTER
THAN YOURS HAVE BEEN --
BUT I DO THINK THAT YOU HAVE
CAPTURED A GOOD DEAL OF WHAT.
THE COMMITTEE HAS BEEN DEALING
WITH THEM REFLECTING ON THROUGH
THE PROCESS.
ANYWAY WE HAVE HELD A NUMBER OF
HEARINGS A BEEN VERY INFORMATIVE
THAT HAVE OUTLINED IN
HIGHLIGHTED.
VARIOUS ELEMENTS OF THIS A
RATHER COMPLICATED AND
CHALLENGING PROCESS OF
NAVIGATING THROUGH IMPORTANT --
IMPORTANT AREAS THAT --
WHETHER IT BE.
PROTECTING THE VICTIMS
RATEPAYERS.
OUR WEATHER'S LOOKING AT
COMPREHENSIVE SAFETY SOLUTIONS.
OUR OR CARVING OUT A POLICY.
PATHWAY OUT TO PROVIDE STABILITY
TO OUR OUR UTILITIES ALL AREAS
OF OUR ARE CRITICALLY IMPORTANT.
AND IN OVER MY IN OVER THIRTY
YEARS OF PUBLIC POLICY AS A
PUBLIC ELECTED OFFICIAL.
OF THIS IS BEEN PROBABLY THE
MOST CHALLENGING AND MANY TIMES
VEXING.
AREA OF PUBLIC POLICY THAT I'VE
HAD TO DEAL WITH.
AND THE RAMIFICATIONS AND THE
STAKES ARE CLEARLY VERY HIGH --
NO MATTER WHICH WAY WE GO OR HOW
WE GO THERE.
AND SO WHAT HAS BEEN ON
PRESENTED BY THE TIME OUR
CULTURE DODD IS A A RECOGNITION
OF KEY ELEMENTS.
THEY SHOULD BE ADDRESSED IN THIS
REPORT.
AND THE KIND OF DIRECTION THAT
WE WERE GREEN SHOULD BE PURSUED.
OBVIOUSLY AFTER TODAY WE MOVED
TO HAVING A REPORT DRAFTED.
WHICH WILL GO INTO GREAT DETAIL
BEHIND EACH OF THESE ELEMENTS.
AND SO MANY OF US EVEN HERE
TODAY ARE GOING TO BE --
FOLLOWING THAT PART OF THE
PROCESS.
AND ENSURING THAT.
A KEY.
AREAS ARE COVERED --
THAT WE FEEL NEED TO BE COVERED
APPROPRIATELY.
AND AND SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO
THE COMMENTS TODAY --
THIS'S BEEN AS I SAID BEFORE A
VERY.
IMPORTANT.
PUBLIC POLICY FOR US TO ENGAGE
JOHN -- BUT
IT HAS BEEN VERY VERY
CHALLENGING.
BECAUSE WE WANT TO AS DO THE
RIGHT THING.
AND WE WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYONE WHO'S IMPACTED BY.
THESE DECISIONS IN THESE ISSUES
ARE.
THAT THEIR PERSPECTIVE IS
RECOGNIZED [inaudible]
AND APPRECIATED.
AND SO I THINK THAT WE'RE MOVING
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
AND I APPRECIATE NOT ONLY THE
VICE CHAIRS --
LEADERSHIP THROUGH THE PROCESS
BUT ALSO.
THE CONFEREES THAT I'VE HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY ENGAGE WITH ALL OF
THE CONFEREES BUT CERTAINLY IN
THE ASSEMBLY.
THE CONFEREES OF WE'VE HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ENGAGE A LITTLE
BIT MORE AND SO I APPRECIATE.
OF THEIR LEADERSHIP THEIR
PARTICIPATION --
AND THEIR COMMENTS THAT HAVE
HELPED SHAPE WHAT'S BEFORE US
TODAY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO MEMBERS --
A SILVERSTONE --
YOU HAVE IT A DEADLINE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO GO FIRST OR THANK YOU.
MISTER CHARITABLE MEMBERS AYE
AYES ONE TO SAY THAT --
I'VE REALLY ENJOYED TO WORKING
WITH ALL OF YOU ESPECIALLY THE
TWO CO CHAIRS AND I VERY MUCH I
SUPPORT THE THE OUTLINE HAS BEEN
SO ARTICULATED --
THE ONLY THING THAT I THAT I
WOULD LIKE.
TO ADD IS THAT --
WHEN WE LOOK AT LANDSCAPE
MANAGEMENT THAT WE HAVE --
TO ALSO INCLUDE CALTRANS
[inaudible]
FIRE WAS TO BUY AN AUTOMOBILE
THAT WAS RESULT OF CALTRANS NOT
MAINTAINING --
LANDSCAPE --
ALSO A PROVISION THAT THE IOC
EXECUTIVE COMPENSATION AND
PREVENTING THE EXPENDITURE OF
UTILITY REPAIR FUNDS TO PAY FOR
ARE YOU EXECUTIV COMPENSATION
PERKS I THINK IS --
A GOOD ONE AND AND THEN WENT
UNDER JOBS A WORKER PROTECTIONS
ON THE COMMITTEE DISCUSSED SO WE
WANT TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
PROTECT THE INTEGRITY OF
UTILIZING ARE WELL TRAINED
PUBLIC FIREFIGHTERS --
IN IN THE EVENT THAT --
WE HAVE WILDFIRES THAT YOU SEE
CALIFORNIA THAT THEY ARE THE
ONES THAT ARE CHOSEN.
TO TALK TO WORK BECAUSE AS FIRST
RESPONDERS AND BACKUP RESPONDERS
BUT IN THE EVENT THAT ALL OF OUR
PUBLICFIREFIGHTERS ARE BEING
UTILIZED IN A MASSIVE FIRE
SITUATION --
HOPEFULLY NOTHING LIKE WE SEE IN
THIS YEAR THAT DUH.
A NON PUBLIC FIREFIGHTERS LOW
THE OPPORTUNITY --
TO PARTICIPATE AGAIN PUBLIC
FIREFIGHTERS GETTING THE FIRST --
RIGHT TO TO BE THERE JUST
CONCERNED ABOUT MULTIPLE
WILDFIRES AND HE'S BEEN OUT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN COVER ALL
THE WILDFIRES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IF IN FACT.
THIS IS AN IMPOSSIBLE.
THANK YOU FOR ALL ALL THE HARD
WORK OF ALL THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I'VE.
REALLY ENJOYED THIS EXPERIENCE
EVER SERVING ON A UTILITY
COMMITTEE NEVER SERVING ON
INSURANCE COMMITTEE HAS BEEN
QUITE A LEARNING EXPERIENCE AND
I'M HUMBLED BY THE EFFORT --
ON BEHALF OF ALL OF YOU
[inaudible]
SO.
NOBODY WANTS TO GO FIRST.
TIMELINE.
SENATOR NO PROBLEM UMMC.
I I TO AGREE THAT THIS HAS BEEN
A VERY COLLABORATIVE EFFORT --
TO BUT IT'S IMPORTANT THAT IT IS
BECAUSE THIS IS AFFECTING.
OF VIRTUALLY EVERYBODY IN THE
STATE AND NOT ONLY IS AFFECTING
US ALL IN TERMS OF LIFE AND
PROPERTY BUT IT'S ALSO AFFECTING
OUR ECONOMY --
I JUST NOTED TODAY I THINK IT'S
IN TODAY'S LA TIMES THE
ESTIMATED COSTS OF LOSS OF
TOURISTIC OF FUNDS FOR JUST ONE
MONTH WAS AT LEAST TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS AND I WOULD
SUGGEST IT'S PROBABLY.
MORE THAN THAT PARTICULARLY FOR
OUR SMALL BUSINESSES THAT DEPEND
ON TOURISM OF FOR THEIR
LIVELIHOOD SO --
THIS THIS HAS ENORMOUS IMPACT
AND I THINK THE CRITICAL THINGS
AND I APPRECIATE THAT WE WE SORT
OF PIVOTED A LITTLE BIT --
AS WE APPROACH THIS ISSUE FROM
OF THE FISCAL HEALTH OF THE
UTILITIES TO FOCUS ON WHAT I
THINK MOST OF US AGREE IS ORTON
CONSIDERATION HERE AND THAT IS
PREVENTION AND SAFETY.
AND SO I APPRECIATE THE FACT
THAT DONE --
WE'VE ALL BEEN FOCUSING ON THAT
AS THE FIRST SECOND THIRD AND
FOURTH.
OF ISSUES OF OUR RESPONSIBILITY
AS WELL A COUPLE THINGS I DID
WANT -- TO
OBSERVE A I APPRECIATE THE FACT
THAT CALIFORNIA --
IS GOING TO BE ENGAGE YOU KNOW
WE NEED OUR EXPERTS TO HELP US
WITH PREVENTION --
WHILE THE IOUS HAVE A ROLE --
EXCUSE ME THE IOUS BUT OF THE P.
YOU SEE HAS A ROLE WE HAVE AN
EXTRAORDINARY CAPACITY HERE WITH
OUR FIRE FIGHTING EXPERTS --
WHO HAVE BECOME MORE EXPERT
EVERY DAY WITH EACH ADDITIONAL
FIRE AND?
I HATE TO CALL IT THE NEW NORMAL
BUT CERTAINLY.
THE DRAMA OF CLIMATE CHANGE AND
ITS IMPACT HAS A REALLY FORCED
US TO REVIEW AND RECONSIDER HOW
WE FIGHT FIRES HOW WE MANAGE
AGAINST THEM.
AND DIE IT'S CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT OUT TO ME THAT --
AS WE A PROCEED WITH OUR
FORESTED LANDSCAPE MANAGEMENT
WHICH WE TALK ABOUT HERE THAT --
THAT IT BE DONE IN AN
ECOLOGICALLY RESPONSIBLE MANNER
AND I THINK THAT WE'VE ALL
AGREED ON THAT WE MAY HAVE A
LITTLE DIFFERENCE IN WHAT.
OF OPINION WHAT THAT MEANS BUT
AGAIN I THINK THE SPIRIT OF OUR
DISCUSSIONS HAS BEEN YOU KNOW WE
RECOGNIZE THE CLEAR CUTTING IS
NOT THE ANSWER ME NEVER GONNA
CUT DOWN A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
NINE MILLION DEAD TREES --
WE DON'T WANNA BLAST ROADS EVERY
NOOK AND CRANNY THAT --
WE RESPECT AND APPRECIATE THAT
THERE IS A PLACE FOR OUR
WILDLIFE --
IN A NEED TO TO HAVE THAT KIND
OF ECOLOGICAL BALANCE SO I
APPRECIATE THAT I KNOW IS WE GO
FORWARD A WE WILL CONTINUE TO
TRY TO MAINTAIN THAT BALANCE.
AND THE OTHER THING --
THAT I I DID WANT TO ASK BECAUSE
I WASN'T CLEAR.
IS WHETHER THE LEVEL OF
INVESTMENT IN OUR GRID HARDENING.
BY -- ARE
I'LL USE WILL BE CONSIDERED
DURING THE CPUC REASONABLENESS
REVIEW.
BECAUSE I THINK THAT.
I IS ONE OF THE THINGS THAT HAS --
BEEN A PRIMARY CONCERN IS THE
HARDENING OF THIS INFRASTRUCTURE
AND RECOGNIZING THAT THE CAR FAR
IN SOME OF THESE OTHER FARMERS
WERE NOT.
THE RESPONSIBILITY OF THE AYE
YOU USED WE KNOW THAT THE FIRES
UP IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA HAVE
ALREADY BEEN DETERMINED TO HAVE.
HAD THAT COMPONENTS AND I WOULD
SUBMIT THAT THE THOMAS FIRE --
THAT -- WHO
WAS SO DEVASTATING AND
DESTRUCTIVE FROM MY DISTRICT --
UNDOUBTEDLY HAS THAT COMPONENT
AS WELL SO.
THIS IS A A A MASSIVE
UNDERTAKING FOR A MASSIVE
PROBLEM AND I REALLY DO
APPRECIATE THAT THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE ALL I THINK BEEN WORKING
TOGETHER WANT TO THANK OUR
CHAIRS AND COLLEAGUES FROM A
BOTH HOUSES IN BOTH.
ASIDE TO THE EYE OF THAT WE ARE.
I THINK REALLY ARE MAKING GREAT
PROGRESS IS STILL.
AND AGAIN I HOPE WE KEEP IN MIND
THAT OF WHAT MIGHT BE GOOD FOR
THE GOOSE IS NOT NECESSARILY
GOOD FOR THE GANDER.
AND THAT WE WORK TO TRY TO BEST
OF THE FIND THE BEST STUFF --
FOR BOTH IN AND GET A BILL OUT
THERE THAT WE'RE GOING TO GET%
PASSED AND SIGNED THIS YEAR I
THINK THAT IS.
AN URGENCY THAT WE HAVE IN --
ARE WORKING TOWARDS CHAU AGAIN I
WANT TO THANK EVERYONE FOR THEIR
EFFORTS.
PREVENTION AND SAFETY THOSE WHO
ARE TRULY THE KEYS.
THANK YOU SENATOR SEMI MEMBER
GALLON [inaudible]
THAT'S THANK YOU CHAIRS FIRST
LIE BACK ON THE SENATORS OF MY
COLLEAGUES THAT TERM.
THIS IS BEEN A OF A LOT OF
HEARINGS A LOT OF STUFFS A
HAPPEN AND GREAT PEOPLE TO WORK
WITH APPEARANCE WHERE WE'RE FACE
WAS A BIG CHALLENGE BUT I WANT
TO JUST KINDA RE COOP --
WHAT HAS HAPPENED OVER THE?
LAST MEETINGS IN WHEREAS SO WE
BASICALLY HAVE TAKEN IN VERSE
OFF THE TABLE.
SO THAT NEEDS TO BE STATED.
SO THAT'S OFF THE TABLE.
WE'RE LEFT WITH.
THE OPTIONS OF IN IN MY MIND YOU
CAN CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG IF
WE DO NOTHING.
UTILITIES WILL BE DOWNGRADED THE
RATEPAYERS WILL PICK UP THAT
COST WHEN THEY GO TO THE PC.
IF THEY GO INTO BANKRUPTCY THE
RATEPAYERS ATTACK OF THE COST OF
THE JUDGE WILL BE DECIDING.
HOW WE GO FURTHER INTO CHAPTER
ELEVEN SO WORTH THE NUMBER THREE
OPTION WHICH IS?
IN MY MIND WE WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT THE INVESTORS PAY THEIR
FAIR SHARE.
DOWN TO WHERE THE U. CHARLIE IS
STILL [inaudible]
SOLVENT.
AND CAN STILL BORROW MONEY AT
THE RIGHT RATES AND THAT LESSENS
THE IMPACT ON THE RATE PAYERS.
AND I THINK THE FOURTH ISSUE
WHICH IS SOMETHING THAT.
IS VERY CRITICAL TO THIS.
OPTION IS THAT WE ACTUALLY DO
SOMETHING ABOUT THE SHAPE THAT
WE HAVE FOR VEGETATION AND
CALIFORNIA.
AS OF THAT AND THAT OPTION
ACTUALLY HELPS EVERYBODY IT
HELPS THE THAT NINE OTHER FIRES
THAT ARE STARTED BY.
THE TRANSMISSION LINE.
WHICH THAT DRIVES DOWN THE RATES
FOR INSURANCE FOR YOUR HOME.
IT HELPS FIREFIGHTING COST.
IT HELPS THEM.
THE RATE PAYERS.
ALL THOSE THINGS HELP.
EVERYBODY CALIFORNIA NOT JUST
THE RATE PAYER OR THE I USE SO I
WANT TO SHARE THAT TOWN.
WE HAVE TO WE HAVE THREE
DIFFERENT TYPES OF VEGGIES FOR
THE MOST PART THREE DIFFERENT
TYPES OF VEGETATION IN
CALIFORNIA.
WE HAVE FORESTED LANDS.
WHICH IS A BIG PART OF SENATOR
WOOD AND MY EYES DISTRICT AND
THEN WE HAVE.
THE OAK WOODLANDS I CALLED FOR
LACK OF A BETTER TERM WHICH IS
THAT INTERFACE BETWEEN THE
FOREST.
AND THE VALLEY'S.
WHERE THERE'S LOTS OF GRASS AND
BRUSH AND THEN WE HAVE THE
COASTAL REGIONS WHICH IS?
PRIMARILY AFTER THE NORTH IT'S
REDWOODS BUT IF YOU'RE IN THE
SOUTH IT CHAPARRAL [inaudible]
SO.
IN FORESTRY WE HAVE SOME VALUE
IN [inaudible]
THE PRODUCT THAT COMES OUT THERE
WITHIN IT WHEN WE GET TO THE
OTHER TWO PIECES OF PIE.
LIKE MY GOOD SENATOR HAS THERE
IS NO VALUE IN [inaudible]
BRUSH.
AND SO WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE FIND.
THE VEGETATION MANAGEMENT PART
SO THAT SHE IS ABLE TO USE THAT
EQUIPMENT TO KEEP THAT BRUSH
DOWN TO A A LEVEL WHERE IT STILL
THERE.
BECAUSE IT NEEDS TO BE THERE
BECAUSE WHEN IT RAINS IT HOLDS
THE SLOPES IN PLACE.
BUT WE ALSO NEED IT DOWN TO THE
LEVEL WHERE WE DON'T HAVE IT.
AT A FLAME HEIGHT OF TWENTY FEET
WE NEED THAT FLAME MIGHT AT LESS
THAN. TWENTY INCHES.
SO THOSE ARE THE THINGS WE TALK
ABOUT VEGETATION MANAGEMENT IN
CALIFORNIA.
HOW WE MANAGE THOSE ARE ALL
DIFFERENT TOOLS IN THE IN THE
OAK WOODLANDS GRAZING IS A GREAT
TOOL AND WE NEED TO BE TALKING
ABOUT USING?
GRAZING WE NEED TO BE TALKING
ABOUT.
MASTICATION THERE'S EQUIPMENT
THAT KNOCKS THE BRUSH DOWN AND
THE FORCED ME TO TALK ABOUT
DOING GOOD.
SOLID.
ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY FOREST
POLICIES AND THAT'S AN AREA THAT
I HAPPEN TO BE DONE A LOT OF
WORK ON WITH --
OTHER MEMBERS OF THIS BODY.
SO I GUESS WHAT I'M GONNA WRAP
UP WAS SAYING IS THAT WE MET WE
BETTER MAKE SURE THAT WE PUT THE
RESOURCES INTO --
OUR BEDS MANAGEMENT PART OF IT
OVER SOME TIME BECAUSE WE HAVE A
LOT OF WORK TO DO TO CATCH UP
WITH THE AMOUNT OF VEGETATION
IT'S GROWN OVER THE TIME WE ALSO
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE MAKE
THOSE --
IOUS SOLVENT SO THAT WE CAN
LESSEN THE IMPACT TO ALL THE
RATE PAYERS SO THAT'S MY GOAL I
THINK THIS IS A GOOD TEMPLATE.
TO DO BOTH THE CHAIRS I KNOW
THAT THIS IS ON IT'S IT'S HEART
WRENCHING TO SEE THE LIVES LOST
WE NEED TO WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY HERE AND IS NOT
GONNA BE EASY THERE ARE GOING TO
BE IMPACTS TO RATEPAYERS THERE'S
IS NO OTHER WAY AROUND.
AND I THINK WE NEED TO BE HONEST
ABOUT THAT BUT WE'RE GONNA MAKE
SURE THAT THE THE THE INVESTORS
OUR HOW THE HECK A LOT OF SKIN
IN THE GAME.
AND WE WILL MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE NOT GIVING JUNE GIANT
BONUSES I'M I'M WITH MY CALLING
ON THAT.
ONE AND BUT AT THE SAME TIME WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THEY'RE STILL
IN BUSINESS BECAUSE WITHOUT THEM --
THE RATEPAYERS WILL BURKE.
HAD THE BRUNT OF THE COST SO
AGAIN I WILL LOOK FORWARD TO THE
LANGUAGE THE DEVIL'S IN THE
DETAILS.
I WILL BE MONITORING VERY
CLOSELY AND I'M MAKING SURE THAT
EVERY I IS.
DOTTED AND EVERY TIAS CROSS
BECAUSE IF WE CAN'T USE THE
TOOLS THAT WERE LAYING OUT ON
THE GROUND OUT THERE NOTHING'S
GONNA MATTER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
SO REMEMBER MAYES.
I THINK A SUMMER DEL DID A
PRETTY GOOD JOB THERE FLOATING
THINGS HAPPEN AND WE'VE HAD A
LOT OF CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THIS
ABOUT ALSO WANT TO SAY --
THAT I'VE BEEN I'M THANKFUL FOR
THE WORK AT THAT THE TWO CO
CHAIRS HAVE PUT AND ALL THAT BUT
IT INTO THIS --
AND THE AMOUNT OF OF DIALOGUE
THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO TO HAVE
IN REGARDS TO THIS --
BETWEEN BRIAN AND I IN THE UP
WITHIN THE ASSEMBLY REPUBLICAN
CAUCUS --
HE'S WORKED A LOT ON THE
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT I'M SIDE
AND I'VE SPENT A LOT OF TIME ON
THE THE THE THE LIABILITY
ALTHOUGH THE RECOVER.
AND I I I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR WHATEVER CONFERENCE REPORT
WE PUT TOGETHER THAT WE
ADDRESSED SOME OF THE STATE'S
RESPONSIBILITY.
WHICH IS THE THE FOREST AND
LANDSCAPE ABOUT MANAGEMENT AND I
KNOW THAT THERE'S THE DOLLYWOOD --
A PLAN AND I KNOW THAT BOTH OF
THEM HAVE BEEN WORKING AN AWFUL
LOT.
I'M ON THIS AND THEY'VE BEEN
DOING A FANTASTIC WORK IN
REGARDS --
TO THE FORCED HIM LANDSCAPE UP
MANAGEMENT SIDE [inaudible]
I THINK.
THE CONFERENCE REPORT THAT WE
ARE THAT I HOPE TO BE ABLE TO
SIGN ON TO THE WILL ALSO THOUGH
ADDRESS.
AT THE QUESTION OF HOW WE DEAL
WITH -- WITH
COST RECOVERY.
HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE --
I USE THAT ARE AMMAN FIRM
FINANCIAL --
GROUND A BECAUSE THE DETAILS
MATTER AND WHAT WE HAVE BEFORE
US TODAY AND WE DON'T HAVE ANY
LANGUAGE IN YET THAT WE'VE SEEN.
AND IN REGARDS TO A TO THAT.
I JUST LIKE A SOME OF OUR DAILY
SAID IT SEEMS VERY CLEAR THAT --
WELL LIABILITY REFORM A DEALING
WITH INVERSE CONDEMNATION IN THE
CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUES THAT ARE
THERE IS OFF THE TABLE ONCE THAT
IS OFF THE TABLE ARE ONLY TWO
OTHER OPTIONS ARE.
EITHER TO DO NOTHING OR TO THING
IT COMES DOWN TO THAT QUESTION
OF THE SAME QUESTION WE'VE KNOWN
NOW 445- MONTHS IS WHO PAYS.
AND WHEN DO THEY PAY.
AND SO THE DETAILS ARE ARE GOING
TO MATTER.
THE DIFFERENCE IS WE KNOW
BETWEEN THE I USE IN THE PO USES
THAT THAT THE THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES SOME ARE OWNED BY THE
SAME FOLKS THEIR SHAREHOLDERS.
AND THE OWNERS OF THOSE
MUNICIPAL CORPORATIONS ARE THE
SAME.
IN REGARDS THE INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITY THEY ARE DIFFERENT THE
SHE THE RATE PAYERS ARE
DIFFERENT THEN THE SHAREHOLDERS.
AND SO ON WERE THINKING ABOUT
THAT LIABILITY THE QUESTION IS
IS.
WHO PAYS AND WHEN WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE WE GET DOWN TO
THE NITTY GRITTY THERE?
WE ALSO NEED TO I BELIEVE
SEPARATE.
A WHAT'S GOING FORWARD AND WERE
TALK ABOUT COST RECOVERY
PROVIDING CERTAINTIES ARE GOING
FORWARD BUT ALSO REALIZE IT
THERE IS GONNA THAT THERE HAS
BEEN AND WE DON'T KNOW.
EXACTLY YET WHAT THE TOTAL
AMOUNT OF LIABILITY IS FOR
WHAT'S HAPPENED IN THE PAST BUT
WHAT I WILL SAY IS WE'VE GOT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THERE IS
CERTAINTY.
OF FOR P. GENIE AND THAT THERE
IS CERTAINTY AS WE GO FORWARD
I'M ONE EMPIRE HOPE THAT THAT
THE CONFERENCE REPORT AS WE TALK
ABOUT COST RECOVERY.
WILL DEAL WITH SOME LEVEL OF
CERTAINTY AND NOT JUST SOME HOPE
SO LOOK FOR THE CONVERSATION.
SO A MEMBER ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOULD.
YES I WOULD SAY THANK YOU THE
CHAIRS AND MY FELLOW CONFEREES
IT'S BEEN ON A FASCINATING
PROCESS SO FAR --
WITH REGARDS TO THE PROPOSAL
BEFORE US --
COUPLE OF THINGS I'D LIKE TO
POINT OUT THAT THAT --
I'D STILL AM LOOKING FOR DETAIL
ON FIRST OF ALL THE IN UTILITY
PROVIDER PREVENTION OF PLANNING
SECTION AS WE LOOK AT THE P. YOU
SEE TO OUR OVER.
PLANS -- AS
PER THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL --
BACK -- AT
OUR FIRST HEARING A ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I I BELIEVE IS
MISSING ARE CONCRETE TIME FRAMES.
THE LANGUAGE IS A LITTLE TOO
LOOSE FROM ME --
STRIVING TO GET SOMEWHERE AND
ACTUALLY GETTING SOMEWHERE OR
TWO DIFFERENT THINGS WHEN I
DON'T WANT TO SEE AS WE HAVE A
SITUATION WHERE THESE PLANTS ARE
ASKED WE PUT INTO PLACE AND THEN
FOLLOW UP.
AND WERE LIKE FIVE YEARS OUT
WERE NOT THERE AND I I YOU KNOW
MAYBE IT DOESN'T HAPPEN THAT WAY
BUT WITHOUT CONCRETE TIME FRAMES.
THE CHANCES OF SOMETHING LIKE
THAT HAPPENING ARE ARE HIGH IN
MY OPINION --
I WANT TO GUARANTEE THAT.
AS WE GO FORWARD THAT
SHAREHOLDERS PLAY FOR TO PAY
FIRST THEY HAVE SKIN IN THE GAME
FROM THE BEGINNING.
I WANT TO GUARANTEE THAT RATE
PAYER DOLLARS ARE USED TO HARDEN
THE GRID.
ARE USED TO INCREASE SAFETY
RELIABILITY AND THAT THERE IS AN
AUDIT TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
HAPPENS -- I
I I I WANT TO BE SURE THAT THAT
THAT MONEY BEING SPENT IS
ACTUALLY SPENT THE WAY IT'S
SUPPOSED TO BE DONE.
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT CHANGES THE
RULES OF FOR THE TWO THOUSAND
AND SEVENTEEN FIRES THAT WOULD
PUT AN UNDUE BURDEN ON ON RATE
PAYERS AND AND AND I'M I'M VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT.
I THINK THESE ARE THINGS I
HAVEN'T SEEN CODES IN THE
PROPOSAL'S --
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING
THAT -- AND
I HAVE BEEN.
PRETTY OUTSPOKEN ABOUT THIS IS
WITH ME FOR VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT.
GOING BACK TO THE ALLEY ó
REPORT IN APRIL OF THIS YEAR THE
RECOMMENDATION WAS THAT WE SPAN
ARE ON AN ONGOING BASIS.
UP BUT IT TO AT A MINIMUM OF TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR -- A
THIRD OF OUR STATE IS FORESTED
AND AND AS YOU HEARD FROM MISTER
DALI -- WE
HAVE A WHOLE LOT OF OTHER A
VARIETY OF LANDSCAPES OUT THERE
BUT THIS WILL TAKE A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF RESOURCES ON AN
ONGOING BASIS. TO DO THIS
JUSTICE IF WE DO NOT COME
TOGETHER AS A COMPREHENSIVE
PACKAGE DEALING WITH THE COST
RECOVERY DEALING WITH STABILITY.
FOR FOR THE UTILITIES AND THE
PREVENTION WE'RE DOING A BIG
DISSERVICE TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN MY OPINION.
SO -- THAT
BEING SAID I LOOK FORWARD TO OF
THE DETAILS IN A LANGUAGE AND
WILL BE.
LIKE EVERYONE YOU KNOW LOOKING
AT EVERY AYE IN EVERY T. AND ALL
THE EASE AN IN THE MIDDLE OF
THAT SO SO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN SENATOR.
CENTER CANNELLA.
THAT WAS CHAIRMAN IN FIRST OR
THINK THE HARD WORK FROM BOTH
MORE CHAIRS THAT WE'VE WORKED
VERY CLOSELY WITH YOU SENATOR
DODD APPRECIATE YOUR HARD WORK.
I THINK THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE PEOPLE
DYING WE HAVE PROPERTY BEING
DESTROYED.
AND SO I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE FINISH OUR WORK IN AND
I'LL SAY.
THIS DOESN'T GO AS FAR AS I'D
LIKE IT TO GO ON SOME OF THE
SEQUEL EXEMPTIONS HOW I WOULD
LIKE TO GO A LOT FARTHER BUT
THIS IS A CONFERENCE COMMITTEE
AND AND YOU.
YOU NEGOTIATE AND AND YOU DON'T
GET EVERYTHING YOU WANT SO BUT I
AM HAPPY WITH WHERE THIS PACKAGE
IS A AND I WANT TO SEE THE WHY
BILLY ISSUE HASN'T BEEN A BIG
ISSUE FOR ME I KNOW IT'S
IMPORTANT BUT IT.
IT WAS A BIT OFFENSIVE INITIALLY
BE TALKING ABOUT LIABILITY WE
HAVE.
LIFE AND PROPERTY --
YOU KNOW PEOPLE DYING OF
PROBABLY BEING DESTROYED.
HOWEVER I THINK IT IS IMPORTANT
WE TALK ABOUT WHY ABILITY JUST
FOR WHAT --
SOBRE DOLLY INNOCENTLY OVER
MAYES SAID.
AND AND I THINK WE TALK ABOUT
LIABILITIES GOING TO BE IN ORDER
RIGHT SO NUMBER ONE WE GOT TO
COMPENSATE THE VICTIMS THEY'VE
GOT TO BE TAKEN CARE OF NUMBER
TWO WE GOT PROTECT THE
RATEPAYERS REPAIR SHOULD NOT BE
ON THE HOOK FOR EVERYTHING.
BUT WE CANNOT BANKRUPT THE
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES IF WE
DO WE WILL SEE MASSIVE INCREASES.
TO ALL OF OUR UTILITY BILLS
BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE DAY
WE'RE GOING TO BE PROVIDING
POWER AND SOMEBODY'S GOING TO
PAY FOR IT.
SO I THINK THE SECURITIZATION AS
IMPORTANT I THINK A STRESS TEST
WHERE WE WE GET AS MUCH OUT OF
THE UTILITIES AS WE CAN AND THEN
WE HAVE TO HAVE A UTILITIES THAT
CAN CONTINUE TO OPERATE SO.
I LIKE WHERE THIS IS GOING
OBVIOUSLY WE GOT A LOOK AT THE
LANGUAGE AND WE HOPEFULLY WE
COME TO AN AGREEMENT ON THAT.
AND WE NEED TO DO A PRETTY
QUICKLY BECAUSE WE'RE RUNNING
OUT OF TIME SO.
I THINK WE MADE A LOT OF
PROGRESS AND I WOULD LIKE TO
FINISH THIS IN AND REALLY THE
ULTIMATE GOAL.
IS LET'S DEAL WITH THE FORCE
MANAGEMENT SO THAT WE DON'T HAVE
THE FIRES THAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE
SO.
I LIKE WE'RE GOING I DO A CENTER
GAINES WHO OBVIOUSLY IS HAS HAD
AREAS OF HIS DISTRICT BECAUSE OF
THE WAY HE'S HAVE FIRES HE HE
WANTS TO ADD --
THAT WE SHOULD CONSIDER --
A BLANK WHICH TO DISSUADE
LOOTERS BY PROVIDING THE CASES
OF GRAND THEFT LOOTING AND
LOOKING OF A FIREARM WOULD BE
CONSIDERED A FELONY --
PER HIM THERE'S BEEN A NUMBER OF
OTHERS THEN INCREASE OVER THE
PAST FEW YEARS A NUMBER OF
SUSPECTS ARRESTED FOR LOOTING --
EXCAVATED HOMES DURING
CALIFORNIA WILDFIRES.
STEALING FROM VICTIMS WHATEVER A
PRECIOUS BELONGINGS AND LEFT IN
THEIR HOMES IS REPREHENSIBLE SO.
THAT HASN'T BEEN SO WE TALK
ABOUT BUT I THINK THAT'S
IMPORTANT TO RUN AT A TIME I
DON'T THINK THERE'S ENOUGH TIME
FOR HIM. TO TO GET A BILL GOING
OVER I'M --
AMID A BILL SO MAYBE WE CAN TALK
ABOUT THAT WE DO LANGUAGE SO
THANK YOU.
IF YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER IS.
THANK YOU AND I TOO WANT TO ECHO
THE SENTIMENTS OF MY CO
CONFEREES AND THANK THE CHAIRS --
IT'S BEEN AN HONOR WORKING WITH
BOTH OF YOU.
THE AMOUNT OF WORK YOU'VE PUT
INTO THIS HAS BEEN AMAZING AND I
THANK YOU AND YOUR RESPECTIVE
STAFFS.
I THINK WE'VE MADE IT CLEAR FROM
THE VERY BEGINNING THAT WHAT WE
WANT TO TAKE CARE OF FIRST IS
THE VICTIMS.
THAT HAS TO BE FIRST.
YEAH MAKING THEM WHOLE AND
MAKING SURE THAT WE DO MAKE THEM
WHOLE.
A SECOND AND I DO APPRECIATE THE
EXPERT TEAMS.
HERE AT THIS THAT AND THE DICE
WITH THE WITH THE WITH SOME OF
THE MEMBERS ON PREVENTION TO
FUTURE FIRES [inaudible]
AND SAFETY.
OF THE THE AMOUNT OF INFORMATION
I HAVE BEEN ABLE TO GATHER ABOUT.
HOW YOU MEASURE A TREE AND HOW
MANY TREES YEAH I ME THAT THIS
IS BEEN AMAZING?
AND I APPRECIATE THE EXPERTISE
OF MY COLLEAGUES IN THAT REGARD.
THE OTHER THING THAT IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO ME HAS
BEEN AT THE VERY TOP.
IS MAKING SURE THAT WE PROTECT
[inaudible]
SOLVENCY.
OF THE RATE PAYERS.
THE RATE PAYERS ARE THE ONES
THAT ARE NUMBER ONE ON MY LIST.
I WANT TO BE SURE THAT THEY ARE
NOT THE ONES THAT SUFFER BECAUSE
OF MISMANAGEMENT THAT THEY ARE
SOMEONE CHOSE TO DO.
BUT HAD A DIFFERENT PRIORITY
THAN THEY SHOULD HAVE HAD.
THE RATE PAYERS MUST BE
PROTECTED IN ALL OF THIS.
I DO APPRECIATE TO THE LANGUAGE
REGARDING WORKER PROTECTION --
IS IN A FORM OF GRANDFATHERING
OUR WORKERS WHO ARE ALSO NOT AT
FAULT IN THIS.
WITHOUT A DOUBT THIS IS SPIN
COMPLICATED [inaudible]
CHALLENGING.
BUT I SINCERELY APPRECIATE THE
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT.
OF THE CONFEREES --
HERE PRESENT.
THERE'S NO QUESTION IN MY MIND
ABOUT THE GENUINE CONCERN OF
EVERYONE HERE.
IN TRYING TO FIND A SOLUTION.
THAT WILL WORK. ONE VERY
SPECIFIC AREA HAS TO DO WITH
BIOMASS --
IT'S AN AREA THAT IN THE PAST
I'VE SAID THERE'S NO WAY WE CAN
AGREE TO BY A MOUSE IT'S TOO
EXPENSIVE IT'S TOO DIRTY.
AND I'VE.
LEARNED FROM THIS CONFERENCE
THAT IT'S SOMETHING THAT HAS TO
BE ON THE TABLE.
BUT NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA ARE NOT THE
SAME.
AND WHEN WE LOOK AT
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
BILE MOUSE IN OUR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES WE HAVE TO LOOK AT
THAT DIFFERENTLY.
BUT I REALLY APPRECIATE
EVERYTHING THAT HAS BEEN DONE.
I THE REST OF OUR COMMENTS AS
HAS BEEN SAID BY THE REST OF MY
COLLEAGUES.
THE BEST A THE COMMENTS WILL BE
LEFT UNTIL WE SEE THE ACTUAL
LANGUAGE.
BECAUSE WE WILL BE CHECKING THAT
AND THE EXPERTISE HERE.
I IS GOING TO HELP US PUT
TOGETHER THE BEST CONFERENCE
REPORT.
POSSIBLE SO I DO THANK YOU FOR
THAT BUT YOU SEVENTY MEMBER A
SENATOR HUESO.
I SEE A LOT OF THE SAME FACES
AND THE AND THE CROWD THAT WERE --
THEY'VE BEEN THROUGHOUT THIS
PROCESS AND I APPRECIATE GETTING
ALL THE INPUT.
FROM FROM THE PEOPLE THE
COMMUNITY IN TERMS OF WHAT ARE
THE MOST PRESSING ISSUES ARE.
I I'M VERY.
I'M A VERY SATISFIED THAT I
THINK WE'VE IDENTIFIED THE MOST
PRESSING ISSUES THAT REQUIRE
ACTION AT THIS MOMENT --
WHAT WE'VE DISCUSSED I THINK HAS
BEEN --
THOROUGHLY DISCUSSED AND AS FAR
AS WHAT'S IN THIS CURRENT.
OUTLINED AYE SUPPORT WHAT'S IN
THE OUTLINE I THINK IT GETS TO
THE MOST PRESSING ISSUES OF OF
THE MOMENT.
NOW CAN WE DO OTHER THINGS --
YES BUT AT THAT MEAN ARE THEY AS
URGENT AS THESE PROBABLY NOT AS
URGENT.
SO I WANT TO JUST ALSO.
THANK THE MEMBERS WHO HAVE
SPOKEN ON BEHALF OF THE
RATEPAYERS SAY.
THANK YOU FOR EXPRESSING YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THE REPAIRS AND MAKE
SURE THAT WE DON'T DO ANYTHING
THAT NECESSARILY WILL WILL SEND
RATES SKYROCKETING THAT'S THAT'S
VERY IMPORTANT.
A I THINK IT'S AN A AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE STATEWIDE IT'S OF
PARTICULAR IMPORTANCE TO MY
DISTRICTS I WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
WE DO THAT.
I ALSO WANT --
TO REITERATE THAT A LOT OF THE
STUFF HAS BEEN DONE.
IN IN IN SOME PARTS OF THE STATE
ALREADY HAS SHOWN.
ENORMOUS --
BENEFITS IN REDUCING THE FUEL.
THAT CAUSES THE FOR THESE FIRES
AND HAS INCREASED RESPONSIVENESS.
TO ANY --
ANY FIRE INCIDENT.
AND MAKING SURE THAT IT DOESN'T
SPREAD IT BECAUSE A LOT OF
DAMAGE.
AND WE'VE ALREADY SHOWN THAT
THAT CAN BE DONE AT SAN DIEGO I
THINK THESE ADDITIONAL POLICIES
[inaudible]
WILL HELP --
IN IN -- IN
ADDRESSING THAT SOME OF THE
PROBLEMS THAT WE WE MAY HAVE IN
SAN DIEGO SO THIS IS.
I AN ADDITIONAL FILTER THAT WILL
HELP HELP TO PROVIDE --
MORE PREPAREDNESS --
WOULD YOU LOOK AT THOSE MAPS AND
LOOK AT WHAT WHAT ARE THE MOST
AT RISK AREAS IN THE STATE THERE
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AND WHILE I KNOW.
THE NORTH PART OF THE STATE IS
IS HAVING THESE MASSIVE FIRES
THAT ARE JUST [inaudible]
A DOING INCREDIBLE DAMAGE --
ALL THE RICH I MEAN IF READ
[inaudible]
DENOTES.
THE THE THE HIGHEST.
A LOT --
POTENTIAL FOR FIRE.
THE RED IS ZONES.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN
THE SOUTH.
SO WE WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO
DO IN THE SOUTH. TO PREVENT
THESE FIRES AND WHATEVER WE HAVE
A FOUR INCH LEFT.
DOWN IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE TO DO EVERYTHING IN OUR
POWER. TO PROTECT US FOREST'S.
AND AND WE'VE LEARNED A LOT
ABOUT THE VALUE OF THE INDIAN
THE FOUR IS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
CAN KEEP.
THE FORCE OF LIFE.
AND THAT WAS PREVIOUSLY --
SOMETHING THAT --
WAS HOTLY DEBATED IN THE PAST
AND NOW IT'S BECOMING VERY CLEAR.
THAT'S THINNING THE FOREST IS
GOOD FOR THE FORCES GOOD FOR THE
LONGEVITY OF THE FOREST.
AND IT'S IT'S GOOD TO HELP GROW.
THE FOOTPRINT OF THE FOREST.
AND THOSE THINGS ARE ARE ADDED
INTO THIS PLAN WHICH I THINK ARE
GOING TO HELP.
IN MAKE SURE THAT OUR FORESTS
CONTINUE TO IT NOT ONLY EXISTS
AND PROVIDE [inaudible]
THE THE THE THE GOOD WORK OF
REMOVING --
GHGS FROM THE ENVIRONMENT AND
AND WHAT THE FUNCTIONING AS THAT
LONG.
THAT ARE CREATING CLEANER FOR
OUR STATE [inaudible]
AND YOU KNOW THE I ALWAYS SAID
THAT THE THE BIGGEST PART OF
THIS BILL SHOULD BE PREVENTIVE
PREVENTIVE MEASURES PREVENTION.
AND AND RESPONSE.
IMMEDIATE RESPONSE TO EVENTS AND
I THINK THAT --
THIS THIS.
OF WHAT'S IN THIS OUTLINE YOU
THINK WILL DO THE THE FURTHEST
IN ASSURING THAT WERE.
WERE AT A BETTER PLACE AFTER
WILL.
WE WE IT PASS A MEASURE THAT
INCLUDES.
A VERY -- A
COMPREHENSIVE PROGRAM THAT STATE
LEVEL TO MAKE SURE WE CAN BE
MORE RESPONSIVE SO THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS. FOR
YOUR HARD WORK.
THANK YOU SENATOR I JUST WE'RE
GONNA GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT --
I TALKED IT LIKELY COCHAIR WE'RE
GONNA DO JUST BE CONSISTENT WITH
WHAT WE'VE DONE ALL ON A MINUTE --
EACH HOWEVER WE BOTH THINK THAT
THAT PRINCIPLES OF THE
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS.
RATE PAYER GROUPS UTILITY GROUPS --
IF USE SEE IT'S GOING A LITTLE
OVER A MINUTE WE'RE GIVING.
A LITTLE BIT MORE LEEWAY
AMERICANS WE WE'VE HAD A
TRANSPARENT PROCESS UP TILL NOW
WE DON'T WANT TO STOP THAT.
SO.
PROCEED CAMANCHE [inaudible]
WELL.
MISTER CHAIRMAN.
SCOTT WHICH ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION OF UTILITY
EMPLOYEES.
FIRST I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
CONFEREES --
FOR THE SERIOUSNESS AND SERVER
NESS IN THE TIME AND EFFORT THEY
PUT INTO THIS.
UNFORTUNATELY.
I HAVE.
TO INFORM THE COMMITTEE THAT
THERE SEVERAL COMPONENTS WITHIN
THE PROPOSED PACKAGE TO HAVE US
GRAVELY CONCERNED [inaudible] TO
SENATOR HANNAH BETH JACKSON SAYS
COMMENTS.
SO REMEMBER WOULD AND DOLLY AND
SEVERAL OTHERS. TO PAY WHAT THE
LANGUAGE LOOKS LIKE BUT WHAT WE
FEAR THE LANGUAGE LOOKALIKES
RELATIVE TO THE FIRE PLANES --
THE GOVERNOR'S LANGUAGES
PROPOSED.
DOESN'T DO ANYTHING [inaudible]
ON HARDENING.
IT IS SIMPLY A REARRANGING OF
THE DECK CHAIRS.
IT'S A RESTATEMENT OF EXISTING
LAW.
AS IT WAS PRESENTED WE DON'T
BELIEVE THAT IT WOULD FORCED
UTILITIES FOR THE P. YOU SEE TO
DO ANYTHING DIFFERENTLY.
IN REGARD TO HARDEN THE SYSTEM.
IF THE LANGUAGE REFLECTS WHAT WE
FEAR IT WILL REFLECT.
WE WE'LL BE OPPOSED TO A
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE REPORT.
IT WILL BE INTELLECTUALLY
DISHONEST. TO PUT FORGED THE
PUBLIC THE YOU HAVEN'T YOU
YOU'VE MADE THE STATE'S STATE
SAFER.
BY MAKING THE SYSTEM MORE
RESILIENT.
WHEN YOU HAVE IT?
AND WE WILL FEEL COMPELLED TO BE
THE VOICE FOR THAT MESSAGE
[inaudible]
SECONDLY.
WHILE THE DEVIL'S IN THE DETAILS
AS WAS STATED RELATIVE TO THE
THE BONDING --
THE REPAIR PROTECTION BONDS.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THIS
COMMITTEE TO UNDERSTAND --
THE REALITY OF WHAT THE
SEQUENCING IN THE TIMING AND THE
POTENTIAL EVENTS IN THE NEXT
WEEK OR TWO CAN BE IF THAT%
LANGUAGE DOESN'T COME BACK AND
DOESN'T PROVIDE A REAL.
AND MEANINGFUL SOLUTION. TWO THE
PROBLEM FACING PGD FROM THE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN FIRES.
FROM THE FOLKS WE TALKED TO THE
ANALYSTS THAT WE TALKED.
THE ECONOMIST WE TALK TO THE
BANKRUPTCY LAWYERS THAT WE TALK
TO THE IBEW.
IF THIS CONFERENCE COMMITTEE
REPORT.
COMES OUT NEXT WEEK AND DOES IT
EFFECTIVELY ADDRESS THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN ISSUE.
YOU'RE GONNA SEE VERY LIKELY.
I DOWNGRADED OF P. GENIE TO JUNK
BOND STATUS.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
WHY SHOULD YOU CARE [inaudible]
SWETA I KNOW.
MISTER CHAIRMAN THIS IS ONE STOP
I WILL CLOSE THIS OUT THIS IS TO
KEEP POINT.
IT SHOULD BE ON THE RECORD.
WHAT WILL HAPPEN AT THAT POINT
IS ALL OF THE POWER PURCHASE
AGREEMENTS THE PGD HAS HAVE CASH
CALLS ASSOCIATED WITH THEM
WHEN THEY GET DOWNGRADED TO THE
LEVEL BEING NOT CREDITWORTHY ANY
LONGER?
THEY HAVE TO PONY UP ABOUT A
BILLION DOLLARS IN CASH THAT'S
BECAUSE IT ILLIQUIDITY ISSUE
ALMOST IMMEDIATELY.
AND PUT PRESSURE TOWARDS
BANKRUPTCY BUT IN ADDITION TO
THAT.
OUT OF THE SIX BILLION DOLLARS
IT TAKES TO RUN PGD ANNUALLY.
THEY NEED TO BILLION DOLLARS
FROM.
THE MARKET WHICH WILL NOW NOT BE
AVAILABLE.
NOT ONLY WILL THEY NOT BE ABLE
TO DO ANY OF THE INVESTMENTS YOU
HOPE TO HAVE THEM MAKE.
BUT IT WILL BE CHALLENGING TO
KEEP THE DOORS OPEN AND KEEP
CALIFORNIA SAFE GOING FORWARD
[inaudible]
THAT'S WHERE THE DEVIL'S IN THE
DETAILS SO WE URGE YOU TO LOOK
VERY CLOSELY AT THAT LANGUAGES
ENSURE THAT IT ACTUALLY ISN'T
WINDOW DRESSING.
BUT ACTUALLY DELIVERS ON WHAT IT
PURPORTS TO DELIVER THANK YOU.
BAKER AND I I'M WORKING TO GIVE --
THE REPEATER GROUPS --
A LITTLE BIT MORE TIME.
THE BALLOT BALLOTS AND I THINK
IT WAS IMPORTANT INFORMATION BUT
JUST TO BE FAIR ON ALL SIDES OF
WE CAN KIND OF KEEP THE TIME TO
BETTER THOUGHT EVERYONE ELSE
AGREES SHE THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN --
JESS BUDDY JOHNSON THE
INDEPENDENT ENERGY PRODUCERS AND
FOLLOWING UP REAL QUICK ON THIS --
IT IS VERY IMPORTANT TO BE ABLE
TO COVER --
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN LIABILITY --
THE RATEPAYERS --
BY AIR AND THE FACT OF THE
MATTER IS FOLLOWING UP AND
MISTER --
WATCHES COMMENTS THERE IS OVER
TWO HUNDRED TWENTY CONTRACTS IN
EXCESS OF TEN YEARS WITH P.
GENIE ABOUT SEVEN OUT OVER SEVEN
THOUSAND MEGAWATTS.
A LARGE PERCENTAGE OF MEGAWATTS
ARE WITH CONTRACTS THAT --
BICU LOWER GOT CLIMATE CHANGE --
THE FINANCE BIOMASS PLANTS ET
CETERA AND THE SCENARIO THAT HE
GAVE WITH RESPECT TO WHAT
HAPPENS TO THE CLICK --
COLLATERAL CALLS ON THOSE THAT'S
REAL -- YOU
DON'T OFTEN HEAR ME AGREE WITH
MISTER WELCH BUT THIS IS REAL --
THREE IP JEANNIE DROPS BELOW
INVESTMENT GRADE WE HAVE BIG
PROBLEMS VERY QUICKLY.
I'VE BEEN IN THIS MOVIE BEFORE
IN TWO THOUSAND ONE THINGS
HAPPEN VERY FAST AND IF WE GET
STARTED IN A TAILSPIN IT DOWN
WITH OUR TELLS BEEN WITH CATALOG --
CREDIT WORTHINESS --
IT TAKES A LONG TIME TO DE PAUL
NEED SOME SORT OF MECHANISM THAT
COVERS --
LIABILITY UP FOR TWO THOUSAND
SANKEY.
THANK YOU WE EXPECTED AGAIN
THANK NEXT NEXT WEEK.
CHRIS ROSE ON BEHALF OF THE
SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP
WERE IN SUPPORT OF BOND
SECURITIZATION WE LOOK FORWARD
TO SEEING IN YOUR FINAL REPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRPERSON MEMBERS IS
GREG COOK WITH THOUGH THE
CALIFORNIA POWER AGENCY I WANT
TO AGAIN --
COMMANDED THANK THE COMMITTEE
FOR THE COLLABORATIVE AND OPEN
TRANSPARENT PROCESS THAT YOU'VE
UNDERTAKEN.
WE ASSISTANCE SINCERELY
APPRECIATE THAT I WANT TO ASSURE
YOU THAT OUR LOCAL GOVERNING
BOARDS WILL PROVIDE WILL
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE.
APPROPRIATE SAFETY MEASURES
WITHIN OUR COMMUNITIES INCLUDING
ALL OF THE PUBLIC AGENCIES
WITHIN OUR JURISDICTION TO MAKE
OUR SERVICES A TERRITORY A MORE
SAFE AND RELIABLE.
COMMUNITY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
IF YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CARE MARTINSON
AMI HAVE OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
FOR YOUR TREMENDOUS WORK AND
FIRST AND FOREMOST.
THANK YOU FOR TAKING UP THE
ISSUE OF INVERSE CONDEMNATION
OFF THE TABLE THAT WE BELIEVE IS
GIVING US THE ROOM TO FOCUS ON
SOME OF THE OTHER CRITICAL
COMPONENTS OUTLINED IN YOUR PLAN.
WERE ALSO PLEASED TO BE HERE
TODAY BECAUSE WE DO FEEL THAT
ANY ADDITIONAL DELAY WILL
FURTHER HARM AND IMPACT --
RATEPAYERS OF VICTIMS AND THE
STABILITY OF OUR UTILITIES OUT
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE FIRE
PREVENTION IN FORCE MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES INCLUDED IN THE
OUTLINE INCLUDING THAT
ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
THIS IS REALLY THE CRITICAL
COMPONENT THAT WILL LAST IN THE
IMPACT OF FUTURE FIRES --
AND POTENTIAL LIABILITY FOR THE
UTILITIES WERE ALSO VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF UTILITY PLANTS
INCREASED SAFETY AND CLAMMY
MEASURES THIS IS ALSO A CRITICAL
COMPONENT TO THE PLAN.
AND WE'RE ALSO I LIKE TO ECHO
THE SUPPORT FOR SECURITIZATION
THIS IS A TOOL THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS USE TO MANAGE OUR
THAT WE THINK IT CAN BE DONE.
EFFECTIVELY AND RIGHT --
FOR INVESTOR AND YOU TO ONLY
MANNER AND WILL KEEP THEM SAFE
IN OUR COMMUNITY SAFE AS WELL.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING OF THE
DETAILS OF THE PLAN AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR WORK.
MISTER SHARES IN MEMBERS I'M
GARY PASS MORE.
OF THE CONGRESS OF CALIFORNIA
SENIORS SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
EIGHT MILLION SENIORS IN
CALIFORNIA.
OR LARGEST AND FASTEST GROWING
POPULATION GROUP.
WELL LET ME FIRST OF ALL POINT
OUT ASSEMBLYMEMBER RADIOS AND
SAY. TWO ARCTUR THANK YOU FOR
YOUR EMPHASIS CONCERNED ABOUT
RATE PAYERS MY HOPE OTHERS UP
THERE YOU DIDN'T EXPRESS IT
SHARE HER POINT OF VIEW
[inaudible]
LAWMEN.
INACTION ON THE PART OF THE
LEGISLATURE WILL CERTAINLY.
CREATE SOME ECONOMIC PROBLEMS
AND CHAOS WELL AMONG THE RATE
PAYERS SO WE'VE GOT TO ACT AND
REASSURE PEOPLE.
THE URGENT ACTION IS NEEDED AND
YOUR REPORT MUST ALSO CONSIDER
HOW TO KEEP THE UTILITIES
FINANCIALLY.
A HEALTHY AND AVAILABLE HOT TO
THE TO THE CONSUMERS OF
CALIFORNIA.
PAY GIVING THEM SOME REASONABLE
TOOLS TO COVER THEIR COSTS.
SO THIS IS PROBABLY THE MOST
IMPORTANT ISSUE FACING THE STATE
AND WE ARE TURNED DOWN AND VERY
CONCERNED THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON STACEY HEATING
RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING THIRTY
FIVE RURAL COUNTIES STATEWIDE AS
YOU KNOW AND YOU ALSO RECEIVED A
LETTER FROM US YESTERDAY AT THE
THIS AND THE PREVENTION OF
WILDFIRES IN THE MANAGEMENT OF
OUR FORESTS AND WILDLANDS.
IS OF TOP PRIORITY TO RC RC SO
WE'RE VERY PLEASED WITH THE
FOCUS OF THIS COMMITTEE.
AND I WITH THE OUTLINE THAT WAS
PRESENTED TO US TODAY.
WE WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH ACTION ON THIS WE
CAN'T AFFORD TO WAIT ANOTHER
YEAR OR ANOTHER SESSION.
AND WE WOULD LIKE TO ASSOCIATE
OUR COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF C.
SAKON ARE MY COLLEAGUE CARE
MARTINSON AND WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WORK AND LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING THE DETAIL THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRPERSON MEMBERS JOEY
DIVORCE ON BEHALF THE URBAN
COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE --
OF THE KENNY TAKING INVERSE CON
THE GOVERNMENT'S --
VERY FROM LOOKING OUT THOUGHT
WHY WE'RE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
THE PLAN MOVING FORWARD ONE TO
SEE IF SOME OF THE DETAILS OF
COURSE.
MAMBA WOULD ALIGN OUR COMMENTS
WITH C. SACK ESPECIALLY ON THE
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT AND
SECURITIZATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON I'M
NANCY PEPPERING THE ON BEHALF OF
THE CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIAN AGAIN THANK YOU TO
THE COMMITTEE.
AYE WE DO SUPPORT THE PARAMETERS
OF THIS PACKAGE AND PARTICULARLY
THE FOCUS ON BECAUSE IN
PREVENTION WEEK THAT JUST HAS TO
HAPPEN.
AND WE ALSO WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR REMOVING THE
PROVISIONS ARE THAT THOUGHT.
THAT THE LEGAL RIGHTS OF
HOMEOWNERS IN THE PUBLIC
ENTITIES WOULD BE AFFECTED SO WE
DO THANK YOU FOR THAT AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK ON THIS HAS BEEN A TWENTY
FOUR SEVEN EFFORT WE WANNA.
BE HELPFUL THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MELISSA CORTEZ ROTH ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA WIND
ENERGY ASSOCIATION AND I WANT TO
ECHO THE COMMENTS THAT WERE
PREVIOUSLY MADE BY THE
INDEPENDENT ENERGY PRODUCERS.
AND AGAIN EMPHASIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF ADDRESSING THE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN LIABILITY
LIABILITY IS NOT JUST A UTILITY
PROBLEM.
THERE IS A DIRECT IMPACT OUR
RENEWABLE ENERGY PROJECTS WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE WE EMPHASIZE
THAT POINT WITH YOU AND THERE'S
A DIRECT IMPACT.
ALSO WITH US MEETING OUR
GREENHOUSE GAS GOALS IF THESE
PROJECTS CAN'T GET FINANCE IT
PUTS A LOT OF OTHER GOALS IN
JEOPARDY.
GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS KENNY SADLER I'M HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
URBAN.
PARTNERSHIP AND WE'D LIKE TO
URGE THE COMMITTEE TO ENSURE
THAT --
CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC UTILITIES
ARE REMAIN FINANCIALLY STABLE
THE FACT IS THAT --
BE JIMMY SUPPORTS ARE A LARGE
NETWORK OF DIVERSE SUPPLIERS.
AND IS IN FACT EH IN THE
INDUSTRY LEADER IN SUPPLIER
DIVERSITY.
AND WE NEED A COMPREHENSIVE
SOLUTION THIS YEAR [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRPERSON MEMBERS I'M
AARON EVANS ON BEHALF OF THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA SAY IF WE
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE WORK
THAT THIS COMMITTEE HAS --
ENGAGED AND THROUGHOUT THE PAST
SEVERAL WEEKS.
OUT WE ARE VERY MUCH ALSO
APPRECIATE YOUR I'M TAKING
INVERSE CONDEMNATION CHANGES OFF
THE TABLE AMEND THAT HAS GIVEN
US THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK
TOWARDS A COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTION.
AYE THE SOLUTION THAT HAS BEEN
OUTLINES TODAY WE ARE SUPPORTIVE
OF AYE IT WILL ADDRESS A
MULTITUDE OF ISSUES SAFETY AND
PREVENTION AND AS WELL AS
ENSURING THAT OUR OUR UTILITY
RATE PAIRED EXCUSE ME THAT ARE
UTILITIES REMAIN SOLVENT INTO
THE FUTURE.
AND WE SUPPORT THE PARAMETERS
WE'VE HEARD TODAY AND LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH YOU AS WE SEE THE DETAILS
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO ED CHAIRMAN STODDEN HOLD
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS TRACY HANSON I'M HERE
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION.
BAR DISTRICT ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE METROPOLITAN
FIRE CHIEFS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WE WANT.
TO EXPRESS OUR SINCERE GRATITUDE
FOR THE MONUMENTAL TASK THAT
THIS COMMITTEE HAS TAKEN UP.
AYE A WE WOULD LIKE TO ENCOURAGE
UNDER FIRE PREVENTION PLANNING
THE INCLUSION OF THE REQUIREMENT
FOR THE UTILITIES TO WORK WITH
LOCAL GOVERNMENT PUBLIC SAFETY
OFFICIALS WHEN THEY DEVELOP
THESE FIRE PREVENTION PLANS.
WHEN THEY'RE INFRASTRUCTURE LIES
OUTSIDE OF THE STATE
RESPONSIBILITY AREA?
WE ARE DEEPLY GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
RECOMMENDATION RELATIVE TO THE
INVESTMENT IN MUTUAL AID AND A
MORE PROACTIVE APPROACH TO
FIGHTING WILDFIRES IN OUR STATE.
AND STAND AT THE READY TO ASSIST
AS YOU CONCLUDE THE PROCESS OF
YOUR WORK ANNA IT WHEREVER
NECESSARY THANK YOU AGAIN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
PALM A SPECIFIC FOR US TRUST I
WANT A BRIEF NOTE THAT --
WITH WHICH HASBRO FORMER SENATOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM NORTH COAST
SENT TO THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE ON
THIS WEEK.
AS THE AUTHOR OF KEY PREVIOUS
CONSENSUS FORESTRY BILLS IN THE
FORMER SENATOR ASSEMBLYMAN FROM
TIMBER COUNTRY.
I MUST STRONGLY OPPOSE A THIRTY
SIX INCH LIMIT FOR FUEL
REDUCTION EXEMPTION AS WELL AS
NO DIAMETER LIMIT FOR SMALL
LANDOWNERS IN.
CONVERSATIONS HAPPENING ON
ASSUMPTIONS.
IN ALL PREVIOUS DISCUSSIONS NO
ONE INCLUDING INDUSTRY EVER
PROPOSED MORE THAN THIRTY INCHES.
THIRTY INCHES FOR ALL INCLUDING
SMALL LANDOWNERS WILL BE
REASONABLE GIVEN THE EXTREME
WILDFIRES CIRCUMSTANCES.
PLEASE STICK WITH THESE
REASONABLE BALANCE FOR OUR
FORESTS BUT WHAT I WANT SHARE
THAT.
ALSO IS NO THE AS WE ARE LOOKING
AT MAKING SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS OF PUBLIC FUNDS TO
MAKE A MORE RESILIENT
LANDSCAPING DEAL WITH OUR FIRE
CHALLENGE.
LET'S MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
FOCUSING ON INVESTMENTS THAT ARE
GOING TO GIVE US BENEFITS OVER
THE LONG TERM.
THAT ARE JUST GOING TO DO IT TO
DISSIPATE AND FOR FIVE TEN YEARS
BUT THEY'RE GOING TO PUT US ON A
TRAJECTORY FOR REAL RESILIENCE
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON LEIA SILVERTHORNE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
CALPERS CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
APPRECIATES THIS IS A
COMPLICATED ISSUE AND WE LIKE TO
PRAISE THE COMMITTEE FOR
ATTEMPTING TO CRAFT A SOLUTION
THAT STRIKES A BALANCE WHILE
ENSURING THE LONG TERM
RELIABILITY OF OUR ELECTRICITY
GRID.
THANK YOU.
pMUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
ONLINE MY COMMENTS ON THE CALL A
GREAT COOK ABOUT THE PROACTIVE
IN ONGOING NATURE --
THAT PUBLIC AND UTILITY WILDFIRE
PREVENTION EFFORTS WE ALSO WANT
TO SAY THAT WE APPRECIATE THAT
KNOWLEDGE MEN OF THE ROLE OF A
PUBLICLY OWNED UTILITY GOVERNING
BOARDS IN THE PROPOSAL OUTLINED
TODAY.
AND THAT WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE ON
THE DETAILS OF THOSE ON WELFARE
PLANS PROPOSED BY THE PROPOSAL
THANK YOU.
CHARACTERIZED PERSONAL INSURANCE
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA LIKED
FIRST THANK THE COMMITTEE SO
MUCH FOR ALL YOUR HARD WORK.
DEVELOPING A COMPREHENSIVE
PACKAGE THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
TODAY.
WE ARE BUT ALSO LIKE TO THANK
YOU FOR CONDEMNATION FROM THE
TABLE WE BELIEVE THAT THIS IS
THE RIGHT DIRECTION FOR THE
COMMITTEE TO HEAD AND OF PLEASED
TO SEE WHAT WAS PRESENTED TODAY.
AND ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
PACKAGE THAT WE'VE SEEN TODAY.
AND JUST THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO
RESOLUTION BY THE END OF THE
SESSION.
CATHERINE PETTIBONE AMERICAN
INSURANCE ASSOCIATION I'D LIKE
TO ASSOCIATE MY COMMENTS WITH
MANY OF YOU ON THE VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT THE PREVENTION.
I THINK IT'S REALLY REALLY
IMPORTANT THE STATE SHOWS
LEADERSHIP ON ACTUALLY REDUCING
THE RISK FACING AT THE WORLD'S
WATCHING THE COUNTRY'S WATCHING
AND I THINK THAT THIS IS WE HAVE
A LOT OF GREAT IDEAS --
AND WE HOPE THAT FOLKS COULD
REALLY WRESTLE THROUGH THE
DETAILS WE'VE HEARD AGAIN AGAIN
THE DEVIL'S IN THE DETAILS DON'T
LET THE DEVIL WHEN IN THIS
WEEKEND.
WE NEED WE NEED SOMETHING TO
COME OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE SO
THANK YOU.
THE CHAIR MEMBERS COMMITTEE OUR
MONTHLY SHOT ON PROPERTY
CASUALTY INSURERS.
ARE LIKE TO THANK ALL THE
CONFEREES FOR THEIR HARD WORK
HOW WE SUPPORT THE CONCEPT
OUTLINED HERE TODAY AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO GETTING THIS DONE
THANK YOU [inaudible]
Q..
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MARIA R. C. ON BEHALF OF
THE CINEMA LANDS TRASK WANTED
SPECIFICALLY TO STAND UP IN
SUPPORT.
OF THAT PROVISIONS FOR HER
FUNDING BEYOND THIS CURRENT
FISCAL YEAR AYE FOR VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT AS WE ALL KNOW AN
ONGOING SOURCE OF FUNDING FOR
THAT IS REALLY CRITICAL BECAUSE
NATURE WILL CONTINUE TO GROW.
AND AS WE GET THE START PROJECTS
STARTED THIS YEAR AND EVEN IN
TWO YEARS WITH SOMETHING THAT I
CONTINUE TO KEEP THAT TO ENSURE
THAT.
AT NATURE'S GROWING IN A WAY
THAT'S NOT TO LIFE AND PROPERTY
THINKING.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS COMMITTEE
AND DANIEL MALES ON BEHALF OF
THE AMERICAN WIND ENERGY
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA CAUCUS.
HONORED TO ALIGN MY COMMENTS
WITH THOSE OF THE INDEPENDENT
ENERGY PRODUCERS IN CALIFORNIA
WIND ENERGY ASSOCIATION.
OUR MEMBER COMPANIES HAVE
EXISTING POWER PURCHASE
AGREEMENTS WITH PGA P. JEANNIE
AND THE OTHER UTILITIES IN THE
STATE.
ITEMS WE WANT TO EMPHASIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF ADDRESSING TWENTY
SEVENTEEN LIABILITY AND THE
INCLUSION OF SOME FINANCING
MECHANISM TO ENSURE THAT THE
UTILITIES ARE ABLE TO CONTINUE
TO HELP MEET CALIFORNIA'S
RENEWABLE ENERGY.
AND GREENHOUSE GAS BECAUSE THEY
KEEP.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
STILL MANY HUNTER ON BEHALF OF
THE SOLAR ENERGY INDUSTRIES
ASSOCIATION AGAIN I ASSOCIATE MY
COMMENTS WITH THE COLLEAGUES
FROM THE RENEWABLE INDUSTRY AND
LET YOU KNOW THAT HEALTHY
UTILITY IS NEEDED FOR HEALTHY.
RENEWABLE INDUSTRY WHICH IS
NEEDED FOR HEALTHY PLANET THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS ROBERT
SPIEGEL CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION REPRESENTING SOME
FORTY THOUSAND OF CALIFORNIA
SMALL AND MEDIUM FAMILY FARMERS
HERE IN THE STATE.
ON GENERALLY FROM THE BEGINNING --
OUR POSITION HAS BEEN TO PROTECT
THE RATEPAYERS WE HAVE NOT
WANTED TO SEE A BAILOUT OF THE
P. JEANNIE UTILITIES OR ANY OF
THE OTHER INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES IN THE STATE.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT THE PROPOSAL
STILL CONTAINS VERY SIGNIFICANT
PROBLEMS FOR SOME OF OUR
AGRICULTURAL RATEPAYERS.
IN ADDITION WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF
THE FORESTRY MANAGEMENT
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT COMPONENTS
THAT SEEM TO BE INCLUDED IN THIS
HOWEVER.
THE PIECE RELATIVE TO THE
CONSERVATION EASEMENTS IS
SOMETHING THAT OUR INDUSTRY IS
GENERALLY OPPOSED --
TO WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
TO WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE ON
POTENTIALLY DRAFTING CERTAIN
MODIFICATIONS TO THAT LANGUAGE
ON PER USUAL WERE HAPPY TO BE.
OF SERVICE TO THE COMMITTEE AND
STAFF AS THIS CONTINUES TO MOVE
FORWARD OF DISCUSSIONS CONTINUE
OVER THE WEEKEND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. TWO MEMBERS WE SUCH AS
WITH THE WESTERN STATES
PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION WOULD LIKE
TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
HOWEVER WE DO REMAIN --
WITH SOME SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS
OVER SOME OF THE OUTLINES HERE
TODAY WE BELIEVE THAT AND ARE
FULLY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
PREVENTIVE PEACE.
OUT THAT SHOULD ALLOW --
A GOOD --
INVESTORS AND CREDIT RATINGS AT
REDUCING THE I USE OVERALL
WILDFIRE RISK.
OUT HOWEVER WE WOULD LIKE ON THE
FIRST POINT --
NOT NOTED IN IN THE OUTLINED
HERE.
TO BASICALLY TAKE IN ACCOUNT AND
ACCOUNTING --
FOR THE INVESTMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN MADE UP TO DATE AND IT'S
CRITICAL FOR US POLICY MAKERS TO
ALSO HAVE THAT INFORMATION
BEFORE APPROVING SOME REFORMS
FOR THE SAFETY MITIGATION PLANTS --
WE NEED WE BELIEVE THAT --
RETROACTIVE IN PROSPECT DIVIDING
IS KEY TO HELP --
HOW CAN ENSURE THAT UTILITIES DO
HAVE SKIN IN THE GAME WHICH IS
SOMETHING ALSO THAT WE ARE
FAILING TO SEE HERE TODAY SO WE
LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH YOU AND
SEEN THE LANGUAGE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
Q..
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE LARA KNOWING HE
TO COME BEHALF OF AMERICAN TO
STASH YOUR GROWERS CALIFORNIA
CITRUS MUTUAL CALIFORNIA
CONGENERS AND GROWERS
ASSOCIATION YOU SEE FARMERS
WEAKENED WESTERN ON PROCESSORS
ASSOCIATION --
WHILE WE APPRECIATE THE AT THE
FOREST MANAGEMENT PERSON IS IN
THERE WE STILL HAVE SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS. TWO THINGS HAVE BEEN
TALKED ABOUT THROUGHOUT A LOT OF
THESE AND COMMITTEE HEARINGS ONE
IS THAT.
YOU WOULD NOT BE LOOKING
RETROACTIVE AND TWO IS THAT
PROTECT THERE WOULD BE
PROTECTION OF REPAIRS.
UNFORTUNATELY WE'RE JUST NOT
SEEING THAT IN THIS PLAN.
I'M UTILITY FIRE PREVENTION IN
PLANNING RATEPAYERS ARE GOING TO
BE PAYING FOR THAT --
I OWE YOU A GREAT PAIR
PROTECTION BONDS ALSO KNOWN AS
SECURITIZATION RATE PAYERS ARE
PAYING FOR THAT --
CP YOU SEE REASONABLENESS REVIEW
AND THAT ACTUALLY CHEFS
LIABILITY PROTECTION MORE
TOWARDS THE UTILITIES AND COSTS
TOWARDS THE RATE PAYERS SO AGAIN.
RATEPAYERS WILL BE PAYING FOR
THAT AND WE KNOW THERE'S BEEN
SOME TALK ABOUT WELL WE NEED
THESE FACTORS IT ACTUALLY SAYS
FACTORS OUTSIDE THE CONTROL OF
THE AYE YOU WILL RATE PEERS HAVE
NO CONTROL OVER THIS EITHER.
WE DON'T MAKE THE PLANS WE DON'T
MANAGE THE SYSTEM SO WE REALLY
DON'T HAVE CONTROL.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING
THE LANGUAGE BUT WE ARE STILL
CONCERNED ABOUT THIS TURNING
INTO SOME SORT OF BAIL OUT THANK
YOU.
YOU [inaudible]
SPEAKER AT I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MICHAEL SAW CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURES AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION.
I THINK I SHARE THE CONCERNS OF
COLLEAGUES HAVE COME RIGHT
BEFORE --
FROM AG INDUSTRY SIDE OF THINGS
THAT THIS --
LOOKS LIKE A BAILOUT SMELLS LIKE
A BAILOUT IN.
CERTAINLY FEELS LIKE A BAILOUT --
AS IS MENTIONED THERE SEEM TO BE
A LOT OF ADDITIONAL.
THE RATE PAYER COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH THIS AND I THINK ONE THING
THAT I'VE HEARD FROM SEVERAL
COMMITTEE MEMBERS --
PREVIOUSLY DURING YOUR COMMENTS
WAS A CONCERN ABOUT SHAREHOLDERS
AND SHAREHOLDERS BEING FIRST TO
PAY.
WE DON'T SEE THAT HERE IN THIS
OUTLINE AND WE HAVEN'T HEARD A
DESCRIPTION OF A SCENARIO IN
WHICH SHAREHOLDERS ARE GOING TO
BE.
FIRST AT THE TABLE IN PAYING
THIS AND THAT WAS ONE OF OUR
PRIMARY AND IN MAJOR CONCERNS
PREVIOUSLY.
THAT WAS EXPRESSED ALL OF YOU
BOTH IN TESTIMONY AND MEETINGS
WAS THAT SHAREHOLDERS HAVE SOME
SKIN IN THE GAME.
AND WE STILL DON'T SEE THAT HERE
AND I REALIZE THAT THIS IS BEEN
CELLS ARE WILL TIMES THE DEVIL'S
IN THE DETAILS ON THE LANGUAGE.
BUT GIVEN THE CONCERNS A REPAIR
GROUPS HAVE EXPRESSED YOU
MULTIPLE TIMES WE WOULD HAVE
HOPE TO SEE IN THIS OUTLINE.
SOMETHING SPECIFIC TO THAT POINT
HERE AND I THINK IT'S MISTER
DALI IN MISTER WOULD BOTH
EXPRESSED PREVIOUSLY.
THEY'LL THIS SPECIFIC POINT THAT
SHAREHOLDERS PAY FIRST AND WOOD
TO THAT POINT WERE DISAPPOINTED
I THINK IN THIS.
YOU KNOW OUTLINED HAS BEEN LAID
OUT THIS MORNING THAT WE'RE NOT
SEEING THAT WE HEAR IT.
BUT WE DON'T SEE IT AND THAT'S
OF CONCERN THREE PAIR HAVE.
WE WANT TO AVOID A BAIL OUT THE
UTILITIES WE UNDERSTAND THE
RATEPAYERS ARE GOING TO CARRY
SOME OF THE BURDEN.
THAT IN THIS SCENARIO IT APPEARS
TO BE.
ALL OR AT LEAST BY AND LARGE
MOST OF THE COSTS ARE GOING TO
FALL ON REPAIRS AND GIVEN THAT
WE ARE ALREADY.
NEARLY 1100%.
ABOVE THE HOUSE NATIONAL AVERAGE
FOR ELECTRICITY RATES.
ON THE INDUSTRIAL SIDE.
WE JUST CAN'T BEAR ANYMORE IT
THIS HAS A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON
OUR ABILITY TO INVEST IN THIS
STATE TO CREATE JOBS.
THAT PROVIDE FOR OUR FAMILIES
AND HELP BUILD THE MIDDLE CLASS.
WE UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF
HAVING A VIABLE UTILITY BUT IF
IT COMES AT THE RATE PAYERS
EXPENSE.
WHAT WHAT HAVE WE GAINED?
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
MICHAEL VOCAL OR ON BEHALF OF
THE AG ENERGY CONSUMERS
ASSOCIATION I THINK IT GOES
WITHOUT SAYING THAT A HAVE A
GREAT DEAL OF RESPECT FOR THE
COMMITTEE CHAIRS AND ALL THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE.
BUT I DO SHARE SOME OF THE
FRUSTRATIONS OF THE OTHER RATE
PAYER ADVOCATES THAT HAVE
BROUGHT FORWARD TODAY.
I'M GONNA FOCUS ON A COUPLE OF
POINTS THAT MISTER WOOD BROUGHT
UP AND THAT IS.
IN ALL THE PREVIOUS DISCUSSIONS
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
PROSPECT OF CHANGES TO THE
LIABILITY CHANGES AND THE COST
RECOVERY CHANGES.
WE'RE NOW SUDDENLY TALKING ABOUT
RETROACTIVE CHANGES TO TWENTY
SEVENTEEN AND WHAT WE WERE TOLD
IN THE BRIEFING LAST NIGHT.
EVEN PRIOR TO TWENTY SEVENTEEN
THIS COULD GO ALL THE WAY BACK
TO THE BUTTE FIRE IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN AND OTHERS THAT HAVEN'T
COME BEFORE THE COMMISSION.
AND THAT IS EXTREMELY EXTREMELY.
CONCERNING TO US.
I WANT TO FOCUS ON THE OTHER
POINT THAT WE HEARD CONSISTENTLY.
AND THAT IS THAT THE UTILITIES
PGA IN PARTICULAR WILL BE HELD
RESPONSIBLE WHEN THEY'RE
NEGLIGENT OR OR THEY FAILED TO
DO WHAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO DO
OTHER IMPRUDENT OR THEY'RE AT
FAULT.
THAT TOO HAS CHANGED UNDER THIS
PROPOSAL OR IS ABOUT TO CHANGE
INTO THIS PROPOSAL BECAUSE
YOU'RE NOT ONLY LOOKING IT
NEGLIGENCE AND FAULT.
YOU'RE ALSO LOOKING AT THESE
OTHER FACTORS.
SO THAT IS A VERY VERY
SIGNIFICANT CHANGE THAT WE'RE
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT.
AND WE BELIEVE I'M I'M GONNA
INVOKE MY WATCH RIGHT AS A RAIL
VERIFY COULD THANK YOU --
I JUST LOVE O. O. CONCLUDED HERE.
AND HELP BOTH OF THESE CHANGES
HAVE A VERY VERY VERY
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT --
THAT IS YOU KNOW AMOUNTS TO A
MASSIVE BAILOUT PGM A AT RATE
PAIR EXPENSE AND I KNOW THAT IS
NOT WHAT WE'RE SHOOTING FOR HERE
BUT THAT'S WHAT IT AMOUNTS TO AT
LEAST TODAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
VERSACE HUES OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE FOOD PRODUCERS
REPRESENTING THE FOOD PROCESSING
INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA I JUST
LIKE TO ECHO THE COMMENTS MADE
ABOUT MY COLLEAGUES ON THE RIGHT
PAIR ADVOCACY.
GROUP AND JUST KIND OF
UNDERSCORED THE IMPACT THAT THIS
IS GOING TO HAVE ON THE FOOD
PROCESSING INDUSTRY AT THIS
FALLS ON RATE PAYERS WE PROVIDE
GOOD JOBS UP AND DOWN.
OF THE STATE PARTICULARLY IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY WHERE A LOT OF
OUR PLANTS ARE.
UP ENERGY COSTS ARE.
OUR LARGEST COST OF DOING
BUSINESS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN IF WE PUT ALL OF
THE WILDFIRE A LIABILITY ISSUES.
ARE SEIZING THE COSTS ON THE
RATE PAYERS THIS OFTEN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY.
SO I JUST ASK THAT YOU CONSIDER
MAKING SURE THAT THERE'S
EVERYONE HAS SKIN IN THE GAME
THAT THIS ISN'T GONNA FALL
DISPROPORTIONATELY I'M ON MY
MEMBERS AND ON PREPARES ACROSS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CO CHAIRS AND
MEMBERS MY NAME'S GREG SOUP ON
THE CONSERVATION DIRECTOR FOR
THE CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT
SOCIETY.
WE'VE BEEN A CONSERVATION --
VEGETATION PRESERVATION SOCIETY
FOR OVER FIFTY YEARS IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND THAT SAID WE REALIZE THAT
THERE IS A NEED. TO PREVENT LIFE
AND PROPERTY FROM BEING DAMAGED.
FROM FIRE AND THERE IS A ROLE.
FOR VEGETATION TREATMENT CLOSE
TO LIFE AND PROPERTY.
LESS SO WHEN WE GET OUT INTO THE
WILDLIFE'S --
I'D LIKE TO TAKE A MINUTE TO
MAKE TWO POINTS FIRST IS WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE THIRTY SIX
INCH DON'T DIAMETER.
LIMIT WE FEEL THAT UP.
OKAY LIST THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DOLLY --
THOSE TAUGHT ARE THE TYPES OF
TREES THAT WERE MANAGING FOR
THAT'S THE GOAL.
AND WHAT MORE THEY DON'T FEED
THE SPREAD THOSE TREES DON'T
FEED DISCREDITS THE ONES
UNDERNEATH THEM THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO FIT.
AND THE LAST THING I'D LIKE TO
SAY IS THAT.
WE HOPE THAT --
THE REPORT IN THE BILL THAT
FOLLOWS ALSO HAS SOME LANGUAGE.
THAT PREVENTS US FROM BUILDING
IN HIGH IN VERY HIGH SEVERITY
FIRE ZONES TO BEGIN WITH HAS A
PREVENTION MEASURE.
IN THE FUTURE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
WE'RE SORRY FOR THE OUT OF
CONTROL CLOCKS APPEAR
[inaudible]
KEEP GOING.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS AZIZA DAVIS GOINGS ON
BEHALF OF THE SACRAMENTO BLACK
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE [inaudible]
EXCUSE ME. FOR NEARLY TWO
DECADES THE PGP CORPORATION
FOUNDATION POURED MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS INTO THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY.
THROUGH ECONOMIC PROGRAMS THAT
SUPPORT WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AND JOB CREATION.
STRUGGLING FAMILIES IN
CALIFORNIA DEPEND ON THESE
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES THAT PGD
PROVIDES TO HELP PAY THEIR BILLS.
WE ALL NEED TO WORK TOGETHER TO
DEVELOP BETTER POLICIES THAT
PROTECT ALL CALIFORNIA
RESIDENCES AND BUSINESSES
ESPECIALLY THOSE POSH VOLATILE
AND ECONOMIC HARDSHIP.
HAVING SAID THAT WE ARE ARMED
AND SUPPORTIVE SECURITIZATION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ERIC HARRIS SOME WITH
THE CALIFORNIA STATE NAACP --
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR ALL YOUR HARD WORK
ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE.
AND I'D LIKE TO SAY THAT
IMPORTANT TO ALL RATEPAYERS OUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND PROGRAMS SUCH AS DOES FOR
LOW INCOME FOLKS REALLY HELP
AFRICAN AMERICANS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AND IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT WE KEEP THOSE PROGRAMS
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRS AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS JOHN MICHAEL
FOR EQUALITY CALIFORNIA AND
WE'RE A MEMBER OF THE BRIGHT
COALITION AND AND WOULD LIKE TO
ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH OTHERS
HAVE SPOKEN ABOUT SUPPLIER
DIVERSITY PROGRAMS AND THE
IMPORTANCE OF THAT LOW INCOME.
I PROGRAMS THAT P. GENIE HAS
STARTED AND CONTINUED AND THE
CONTINUITY OF THOSE PROGRAMS AND
THE IMPORTANCE THAT THEY HAVE
FOR LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS
INCLUDING LGBTQ CALIFORNIANS --
AND OUR OUR WORK FRANKLY ON
SUPPLIER DIVERSITY WITH EUGENIE
AND WITH OTHERS IN THIS INDUSTRY
I'M WE WE WANT TO SEE THAT
CONTINUE AND BE ABLE TO KEEP
WORKING ON THOSE PROGRAMS AND WE
SEE.
THE PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU ALL
TODAY AS AN IMPORT.
PROPOSAL FOR THOSE REASONS THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRS AND
MEMBERS CASSANDRA COUGH WITH
CALPINE --
WE HAVEN'T HAD THE VISIBILITY
THAT MANY PEOPLE HAVE HERE INTO
THE CONFERENCE COMMITTEES --
KEY DETAILS BUT I RAN OVER HERE
THIS AFTERNOON BECAUSE OF ALL
THE RAMPANT RUMORS THAT WE'RE
NOT GONNA DO ANYTHING ABOUT.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN I'VE BEEN
WATCHING THIS AND I CAN'T EVEN
IMAGINE THE STRUGGLES YOU HAVE
TRYING TO BALANCE ALL THE
DIFFERENT SIDES BUT I ALSO CAN'T
IMAGINE THAT YOU'RE GONNA PUT AT
RISK.
NOT ONLY COMPANIES LIKE MYSELF
WHICH HAVE CONTRACTS WITH THE
UTILITIES AND ARE THOUSANDS OF
WORKERS.
BUT ALSO THE COMPANIES THAT
SUPPLY THE JANITORIAL SERVICES
TO BE UTILITIES A BANKRUPT
UTILITY IS NOT A GOOD FOR ANY
BIG BUSINESS SMALL OR LARGE.
OBVIOUSLY OTHER RATE CARE
CONCERNS THAT NEED TO BE MANAGED
BUT I'M CONFIDENT YOU CAN DO
THIS SO I WANT TO ENCOURAGE YOU.
TO HAVE A SOLUTION FOR TRY AT
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THANK YOU.
HOPE BECAUSE CHAIR MEMBERS JOHN
WHITE WITH THE CLEAN POWER
CAMPAIGN --
WE TO APPRECIATE THE THE
MAGNITUDE OF THE STRUGGLE AND
THE COMPLEXITY THAT YOU'VE BEEN
DEALING WITH WE ALSO UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE'S A LOT OF THE
DETAILS TO STILL BE UNDERSTOOD
BUT THAT BUT THE BIG PICTURE
LEVEL WE NEED TO PRESERVE THE
FINANCIAL.
VIABILITY THE UTILITIES FOR
REASONS NOT JUST RELATED TO THAT
RENEWABLE CONTRACT.
AND THE FUTURE OF CLEAN ENERGY
BUT ALSO BECAUSE WE'RE FINANCING.
A GOOD PART OF OUR CLIMATE
CHANGE --
INVESTMENTS A WEATHER SELECTOR
VEHICLE CHARGING OR WHETHER IT'S
A STRENGTHENING OF IN REDUCING
THE EMISSIONS FROM THE GRID SO
WE NEED TO KEEP THEM HOLE IS AS
BEST WE CAN CONSIDERING ALL THE
OTHER EQUITIES THAT HAVE TO BE
BALANCED WE THINK YOU'RE DOING A
GOOD JOB WE WILL NOT.
KNOW IT'S HARD BUT WE APPRECIATE
YOUR SERVICE AND FOR TO SEE IN A
WORK PRODUCT.
SPEAKER.
GOOD AFTERNOON WE ANY TAKA WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASIAN PACIFIC
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE I LIKE TO
THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR HARD WORK
ON THIS PRESSING ISSUE.
I'M WE URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
REFORM OUR STATE'S OUTDATED LAWS
AND MOVE FORWARD WITH A
COMPREHENSIVE PLAN FOR WILDFIRE
MANAGEMENT.
IT'S CRITICAL THAT THE STATE
STRENGTH AND EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS AND SET FORTH
APPROPRIATE POLICIES TO RESPOND
TO THE MOUNTING WILDFIRE RISK
THAT IS ONLY WORSE IN MY CLIMATE
CHANGE THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN --
MY NAME'S KIM DELFINO ON THE
CALIFORNIA DIRECTOR WITH
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE I JUST
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
THE WORK THAT THEY'VE DONE
THAT'S FAR ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE WE APPRECIATE THOUGH --
FOCUS ON INVESTMENT TO IS I DO
FUEL TREATMENTS ON THEIR
PROPERTY THAT IS ABSOLUTELY
IMPORTANT.
I DO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT ONE ISSUE
THOUGH AND IT'S ALREADY BEEN
REFERENCE WAS WHICH IS THIS
EXEMPTION FOR EITHER THE CURRENT
EXEMPTION WHICH IS THREE HUNDRED
ACRES FOR FUEL TREATMENT FROM.
GETTING A TIMBER HARVEST PLAN OR
ANY ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW AND
THEN A DISCUSS SMALL LANDOWNERS
EXEMPTION.
I THINK YOU KNOW PEOPLE OF THE
ENVIRONMENT COMMITTEES OPEN TO
THAT DISCUSSION THE CURRENT
LIMIT IS AT TWENTY SIX INCHES
YOU CANNOT HARVEST TO TREAT
GREATER THAN TWENTY SIX INCHES
OTHERWISE YOU HAVE.
TO DO ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW.
PEOPLE REFERENCE THIRTY SIX
INCHES THAT'S OBVIOUSLY AN
ENORMOUS TREE AND THAT IS A NON
STARTER THIRTY INCHES WITH
SOMETHING THAT THE THAT THE THAT
THE FORESTRY INDUSTRY THEMSELVES
HAS SAID.
THAT WOULD BE A SUFFICIENTLY
SIZED DIAMETER IN ORDER TO MAKE --
TREATMENT ECONOMICALLY FEASIBLE
THAT SHOULD BE WHERE YOU LAND
NOT THIRTY TWO NOT THIRTY FOUR
NOT THIRTY SIX THANK YOU. ONE OF
THEM WE DON'T KNOW WITHOUT UPON
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU FOR ALL
YOUR IMPORTANT WORK THAT YOU
HAVE DONE --
ITEM ON CALIFORNIA'S EXTREMELY
CONCERNED WITH THE IMPACTS OF
THIS YEAR'S OF FIRES ON
RESIDENTS OF CALIFORNIA THEIR
PROPERTY AND WILDLIFE HABITAT
THROUGHOUT THE STATE --
ARE LIKE TO REFERENCE --
AND ALLY MY COMMENTS WITH THOSE
OF THE PREVIOUS SPEAKER --
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE --
AS LEGISLATION POLICY DECISIONS
REGARDING VEGETATION MANAGEMENT --
CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD WE
BELIEVE THAT THESE POLITICIANS
BE I SHOULD CONSIDER RESPONSIBLE
STEWARDSHIP.
DOT TOWARDS WILDLIFE AND AND
THEIR HABITAT AS PART OF THAT
PROTECTION OF PEOPLE COMMUNITIES
AYE SUCH YOU KNOW WE DON'T
BELIEVE THAT --
A THIRTY SIX INCH THE
RESPONSIBLE SOLUTION TO THAT
THANK YOU.
CHEN MEMBERS NIKITA CROWDED WITH
THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIRELESS WORK ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO REVIEWING THE
PROPOSAL IN GREATER DETAIL
AGAINST FOUR PRINCIPAL CRITERIA.
IS THAT ASSIST THE VICTIMS TO
THE PREVENT FUTURE FUTURE
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES IS
PROTECTED TWENTY CUSTOMERS AND
IS A CONSISTENT WITH
CALIFORNIA'S COMMITMENT TO
ENVIRONMENTAL STEWARDSHIP IN A
CLEAN ENERGY FUTURE.
OF WHAT WE'VE SEEN TODAY WE
THINK THE PROPOSAL MEETS THOSE
CRITERIA SEVERAL KEY AREAS BUT
FALL SHORT OF FALLS SHORT.
I'M IN IN A COUPLE OF OTHERS AND
I'D LIKE TO ALIGN MY COMMENTS
WITH THOSE OF DEFENDERS IN THE
PACIFIC FORCE TRUST ON THE TREE
DIAMETER ISSUE.
THE OUTSIDE WE SUPPORT INCREASED
INVESTMENTS IN FIRE PREVENTION
AND CARBON REDUCTION ACTIVITIES
AND MAKING THOSE SUSTAINED AS
OPPOSED TO ONE TIME COMMITMENTS.
I WAS SUPPORT IN PRINCIPLE THE
CONCEPT OF REPAIR PROTECTION
BONDS TO PROVIDE URGENTLY NEEDED
RELIEF TO WHILE FIRE VICTIMS
WELL TO STABILIZING THE
FINANCIAL HEALTH OF OUR ELECTRIC
UTILITIES.
ITALY'S FINANCING COSTS CONTINUE
TO ESCALATE CUSTOMERS WILL PAY
FOR IT HIGHER BILLS AND WE KNOW
FROM EXPERIENCE THAT UTILITY
BANKRUPTCIES ANYA LOTS OF STATE
CONTROL OVER CRITICAL PART OF A
CLEAN ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE.
THANK YOU.
BEFORE THE NEXT WEEK HER WHICH
ONE MAKE IT CLEAR THERE'S
NOTHING ABOUT THREE DIAMETER THE
THING [inaudible]
NOT [inaudible]
GO AHEAD.
I WILL ASSURE YOU I'M NOT
PROPOSING THIRTY SIX INCHES THAT
CAME FROM STE I DON'T KNOW WHERE
BUT WORK THAT'S NOT PART OF THE
DOLLYWOOD PROCESS [inaudible]
THERE.
DAVID KITANA WITH UP FROM THE
ASHES REPRESENTING WILD FOR
VICTIMS FROM THROUGHOUT THE
STATE -- BY
REMOVING INVERSE CONDEMNATION
AND SPEEDING UP VICTIM RECOVERY
WE THANK YOU FOR COMING UP WITH
A SOLUTION THAT THE VICTIMS CAN
CAN SUPPORT [inaudible]
IF YOU.
I GOOD AFTERNOON KELLY BOYD WITH
THAT CALIFORNIA LOW CARBON FUEL
AND ENERGY COALITION --
BY ONE FOR STRICT MECHANICS TO
SENATOR JACKSON WHO WAS HERE IN
THE SAME ROOM ALMOST EIGHTEEN
YEARS AGO DEALING WITH THE A
SIMILAR --
FINANCIAL SITUATION IMPENDING
BANKRUPTCY FOR VERY DIFFERENT
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT WERE LESS
ABOUT THINGS OUT OF CONTROL AND
AND I THINK THERE'S A MUCH
BRIGHTER LINE NOW.
ON WHAT UTILITIES CAN AND CAN'T
CONTROL THEIR SOLVENCY --
IS IMPORTANT TO THE STATE'S A
IT'S THAT OUR COUNTERPARTIES TO
THEIR CONTRACTS TO THEIR
CUSTOMERS TO THE SECURITY OF THE
STATE I THINK WE KNOW WHAT WE
NEED TO DO IT I I TUST ALL OF
YOU TO DO THAT --
I ALSO WANTED TO ADDRESS A
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES WHO S. SAID
BIOMASS NEEDS TO BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION BIO ENERGY IS KEY --
AND AS YOU KNOW FROM --
LANGUAGE FOLKS HAVE SEEN AB
EIGHT NINETY THREE THEY WANT TO
BE THE MOST ENVIRONMENTALLY
RESPONSIBLE SOLUTION AND THE
MOST EFFICIENT THEY WANT TO DO
THIS IN THE MOST EFFICIENT WAY
TO ADDRESS THE EMERGENCY.
WE THANK YOU FOR CONSIDERING
THAT THANK YOU.
KISSIN THANK YOU FOR REMINDING
ME HOW OLD I THINK YEAH.
GOOD AFTERNOON IGNACIO HERNANDEZ
IN BEHALF OF TURNED UTILITY
REFORM NETWORK RESIDENTIAL
RATEPAYERS.
OTHER NUMBER OF DETAILS THAT
WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO
REVIEWING --
BUT THE LANGUAGE COMES OUT AND
ME JUST MENTION A COUPLE KEY
POINTS. FOR US AYE NUMBER ONE
AND I THINK.
AT LEAST SOMEWHAT --
THE OUTLINE DOES CREATE KIND OF
AIR TYPE PROTECTION. FOR
RATEPAYERS IN THE EVENT THAT --
UTILITIES FOUND TO BE IMPRUDENT --
AND THAT'S REALLY REALLY KEY FOR
US IT HAS TO BE AIRTIGHT.
I UNDERSTAND THAT MIGHT BE BE
FINANCIAL BURDEN FOR THE
UTILITIES BUT IF THEY'VE ACTED
IMPRUDENTLY.
THEN IT SHOULD STILL REMAIN WITH
UTILITIES --
ON THE ISSUE OF THE RATE PAYER --
BONDS --
PROTECTION BONDS WHAT'S GOING TO
BE KEY FOR US IS TO SEE WHETHER
OR NOT.
THOSE BONDS OR AN OPTION
PROVIDED TO THIS DEEP YOU SEE OR
IS IT THE ONLY OPTION AND THAT'S
IMPORTANT FOR THE FOLLOWING
REASON --
THE COMMISSION WILL DETERMINE
IMPRUDENT SEE WHETHER SOMEONE
ACTED PRUDENTLY ARE NOT.
THEN THEY WILL SAY OKAY FOR THE
NON NEGLIGENT LIABILITY.
THESE BONDS WILL BE USED THAT
MEANS ON 101100%.
OF THE NON NEGLIGENT LIABILITY
WILL GO TO RATEPAYERS YES IT'S
FINANCED YES IT MAY BE LOWERED
OVER A NUMBER OF YEARS.
BUT IF IT'S THE ONLY OPTION FOR
THE COMMISSION THEN IT'S THE
RATEPAYERS WILL PAY TO US WE
THINK THAT'S PROBLEMATIC IN THE
SAME WAY THAT UTILITIES.
WILL ARGUE THEY SHOULDN'T PAY.
FOR LIABILITY DOT THEY WERE NOT
NEGLIGENT.
FOR RATEPAYERS TO SAY WELL.
WE PAID FOR ALL OF PREVENTION
[inaudible]
ACTIVITIES AND WHY IS IT THE
UTILITY GETS THE LEGAL BENEFIT
OF IT AND WE DON'T SO.
THE BONDS COULD BE ONE OPTION
SHOULDN'T BE THE ONLY OPTION
THERE SHOULD BE OTHER WAYS TO
MAYBE SOCIALIZING.
MAYBE THERE SHOULD BE FUNDS
MAYBE SHOULD BE OTHER WAYS IT
SHOULD JUST BE.
ONE OF THE COMMISSION CAN A
PORTION THE NON NEGLIGENT
LIABILITY NOW.
I'M IT'S SO THAT SHOULDN'T BE
TAKEN OFF THE TABLE JUST TWO
VERY QUICK THINGS.
BOB ONE IS WE DO APPRECIATE --
COMMENTS BY A NUMBER OF YOU
ABOUT RAPE PAIR PROTECTION AND
IN PARTICULAR WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT KIND OF THE POTENTIAL
STRESS TESTS [inaudible] FOR
UTILITIES.
WE ALSO NEED TO LOOK AT IS THERE
A LIMIT OR A LINE THAT WE
SHOULDN'T CROSS FOR RATEPAYERS --
SO IF WE ARE GONNA ASK REPAIRS
TO PAY SOME PORTION OF THIS.
WHERE'S THE STRESS TEST OR
WHERE'S THE ALICE IS TO SAY OKAY
THAT'S LITTLE TOO MUCH I
REMEMBER RATEPAYERS OUR PAIN FOR
PREVENTION ACTIVITIES NOW.
WILL BE PAYING FOR THE
ADDITIONAL --
ACTIVITIES THAT ARE CONTAINED IN
THE CONFERENCE COMMITTEE
LANGUAGE AND OTHER THINGS
OUTSIDE SO IT'S REALLY REALLY
KEY TO JUST REALIZE.
THE RATEPAYERS CANNOT BE
INSURERS OF LAST RESORT QUE
THERE AND HAS TO BE SPREAD
AROUND WILL BE LOOKING AT THAT --
THE LAST THING IS WILL BE
LOOKING OBVIOUSLY THE KEY
FACTORS --
THAT WILL BE INCLUDED IN THE THE
PRUDENCE REVIEW AND AGAIN WE
WANT HI --
AND NOT PUSHING IT ONE WAY OR
THE OTHER SETS CAN REALLY CAN BE
KEY I THINK ALL THE MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS COMMUTING STAFF FOR THE
WORK YOU'VE DONE SOME REAL
CHALLENGE.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO GIVING
EVEN FURTHER AYE RESPONSE WHEN
WE SEE THE DETAILS THANK --
JR MEMBERS HAS CERTAINLY HAS
ONLY HALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL VERY
STRONG SUPPORT --
YOU'VE HEARD A LOT OF THE ISSUES
THAT ARE SIMILAR TO OUR REASONS
FOR SUPPORTING THIS AND THAT IS.
SECURITIZED THING IN MAKING SURE
THE TWO LADIES ARE FINANCIALLY
VIABLE I CAN'T STRESS ENOUGH
THAT THESE PROJECTS THAT THEY
PROCURED.
WERE SOME OF THE MOST BORN
PROJECTS DURING THE GREAT
RECESSION ONE ON MEMBERS WERE
EXPERIENCING 50% UNEMPLOYMENT.
IT WAS POLICY POLICIES SUCH AS
THE RP ASKED THAT UTILITIES ARE
CENTRAL WITH THAT ALLOWED FOR
OUR MEMBERS TO CONTINUE PUT FOOD
ON THE TABLE.
WE KNOW THIS IS A TOUGH ISSUE WE
THANK YOU AND THE STAFF OF
WORKING VERY DILIGENTLY TO MAKE
SURE.
THAT UTILITIES REMAIN SAFE AND
VIOLENT THAT FIRST.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME SHANNON
AT HIM WITH A LARGE SCALE SOLAR
ASSOCIATION OVER AMPLIFY MR DS'S
COMMENTS --
AND AND THANK YOU FOR STEPPING
UP TO TAKE ON WHAT WILL BE
INEVITABLY SOME VERY DIFFICULT
DECISIONS.
ON WE WOULD ASK THAT YOU DO
ADDRESS THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
LIABILITIES THAT YOU DO ALLOW
THOSE TO BE FINANCED --
AND THAT YOU KEEP EUGENIE
HEALTHY IN AND TO PRESENT THEIR
UTILITY FROM FALLING INTO A A
JUNK BOND STATUS THAT WOULD
JEOPARDIZE.
A LOT OF JOBS THAT WOULD
JEOPARDIZE THE RENEWABLE ENERGY
CONTRACTS.
IT WOULD THREATEN INVESTOR
CONFIDENCE IN INVESTING IN
CALIFORNIA RENEWABLE ENERGY
PROJECTS GOING FORWARD AND
FURTHER DISRUPT THE MARKET SO.
THANKS FOR CONSIDERATION.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TONY
GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BY MALES ENERGY
ALLIANCE --
WE WILL UNWANTED INDICATE OUR
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE PROPOSAL
IN CONCEPT --
MEMBERS KNOW THE IMPORTANCE OF A
FORCE MANAGEMENT --
BIOMASS INFRASTRUCTURES WELL
FIRE -- BUT
PREVENTION AND ENERGY OF THE
RENEWABLE ENERGY A WE SUPPORT
THE WORK OF THE COMMITTEE AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
CHAIRMEN DOT CHAIRMAN HOLDEN
ENTERING AND WE WOULD SHOW YOUR
HANDS WE HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
ADVANCED ENERGY ECONOMY.
I WOULD THINK THE COMMITTEE FOR
THE WORK --
THAT HAS BEEN PUT IN TO MOVE THE
DIALOGUE ON THIS ISSUE.
IN A VERY CONSTRUCTIVE --
DIRECTION.
THE MEMBERS OF OUR ASSOCIATION
EIGHT OF LEAD TO PANDER AND
DEVELOP TECHNOLOGY SOLUTIONS
THAT MAKE THE GRID.
AND TRANSPORTATION SECTOR.
MORE CLEAN AND AFFORDABLE.
UTILITY FINANCIAL INSTABILITY
WOULD HAVE A DETRIMENTAL IMPACT
ON MANY OF THESE INVESTMENTS.
AND THE STATE AND TECHNOLOGY
INNOVATION THAT WILL BE NEEDED.
TO MEET THE STATE'S GOALS.
IT IS VITAL THAT UTILITIES HAVE
A FINANCIALLY VIABLE FUTURE.
AND WE HOPE THIS DISCUSSION WILL
LEAD TO A WORKABLE SOLUTION.
WE THANK YOU FOR THE TIME AND
EFFORT YOU PUT INTO IT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CARRY HAD OF THAT FOR
THE NEXT AT A NEXTERA ENERGY
RESOURCES WHERE LARGE CLEAN
ENERGY INVESTOR IN THE STATE
WITH INVESTMENTS AND WIND
[inaudible]
SOLAR TRANSMISSION AND ENERGY
STORAGE OUT WE SUPPORT
SECURITIZATION A TWENTY
SEVENTEEN LIABILITY FOR P.
JEANNIE.
AND LIKE MANY OF THE FOLKS
REPRESENTING CLEAN ENERGY
COMPANIES HERE IT'S CRITICAL FOR
FINANCIAL STABILITY A PEACH ME.
NOT ONLY TO MAINTAIN THE
VIABILITY OF THE CONTRACTS THAT
SIGNED BUT ALSO THE FINANCIAL
HEALTH FOR INVESTMENTS GOING
FORWARD.
WE ALSO SUPPORT AS A GENERAL
MATTER JUST GREAT RECOVERY FOR
NON NEGLIGENT --
CLAIMS GOING FORWARD SO THAT WE
INCREASED INVESTOR CONFIDENCE
AND THE UTILITIES ABILITY TO
INVEST IN THE STATE.
AT A LOW COST OF CAPITAL.
AND AND THE ENERGY INDUSTRY IS
VERY CAPITAL INTENSIVE ACCESS TO
LOW COST CAPITAL IS CRITICAL FOR
US TO MAINTAIN OUR CLIMATE GOALS
AND CONTINUE INVESTMENT IN THE
STATE [inaudible]
IF YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
TIFFANY FANNED OUT OF THE
CALIFORNIA EFFICIENCY DEMAND
MANAGEMENT COUNCIL WE BELIEVE
CALIFORNIA'S WORLD LEADING
ENERGY EFFICIENCY PROGRAMS IT'S
PROBABLY GROWING PROGRESS IN
DEMAND SIDE MANAGEMENT.
AND THE HUNDREDS OF COMPANIES
AND MANY THOUSANDS OF JOBS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE --
THAT THE SUPPORT ALL DEPENDENT
ON HEALTHY SOLVENT INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES THE INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES ACCESS TO LOW
COST CAPITAL HAS BEEN A KEY
DRIVER OF CALIFORNIA'S CLEAN
ENERGY GOALS.
AND ARE ESSENTIAL PART.
OF CALIFORNIA'S CONTINUED
SUCCESS.
WE ASK THE COMMENTS ME TO WORK
TO FIND SOLUTIONS THAT ARE FAIR
EQUITABLE. TO ALL CONCERNED AND
THAT ENSURE THE INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES ARE ABLE TO CONTINUE
THEIR IMPORTANT ROLE.
AND CONTRIBUTE TO CALIFORNIA'S
CLEAN ENERGY FUTURE THINKING.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR DODD TEAR
HOLDEN MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE
LOOK AT FACTS ON BEHALF THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY.
OUT WE SUPPORT A COMPREHENSIVE
APPROACH RESTORING OUR FORESTS
HOW WE BELIEVE THAT THE STATE
MUST INCREASE THE PACE AND SCALE
OF ECOLOGICALLY BASED FORCE
MANAGEMENT WITH RESOURCES TO
MATCH THIS GREAT CHALLENGE.
OUT WE ALSO SUPPORT THE PROPOSED
CONSISTENT FORCE MANAGEMENT FROM
THE GDR AFTER THE CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE IS NOW CONSIDERING
THANKS VERY MUCH.
YOU'RE ALMOST AT THE END.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO THAT
COMMITTEE YOU'VE WORKED SO HARD
ON SUCH AN INCREDIBLY COMPLEX
AREA JUST LISTENING TO ALL THE
TESTIMONY TODAY.
OUT LEON TRACKING REPRESENTING
THE ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND.
WE WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF MANAGING OUR
FORESTS SO THAT WE CAN PROTECT
OUR CLIMATE THE FOREST FIRES IN
ADDITION TO DEVASTATING
NEIGHBORHOODS FAMILIES
BUSINESSES.
ALSO DEVASTATE OUR CLIMATE.
AND AT THE SAME TIME WE HAVE TO
BE CAREFUL THAT WE MAINTAIN THE
SOLVENCY OF THE I AO USE AS
THEIR AN INTEGRAL PART IN OUR
MARCH TOWARD.
BUILDING A MORE I'VE.
OUR OUR BUILDING OUR ENERGY ON
RENEWABLE SOURCES SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND LOOK FORWARD TO
THE DETAILS BUT THAT BOB THAT I
DOLLYWOOD PROPOSAL WE HAVE TO
MAKE SURE THAT YOU FOLLOW THE
QUADRATIC MEAN EQUATION.
THAT I GET IT RIGHT --
AND BUT SERIOUSLY WE CAN'T USE
THIS AS AN EXCUSE TO BE GOING
AND CUTTING THE TREES THAT
THIRTY SIX INCH BY INCH DIAMETER
THINKING.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN.
HOLDEN CHAIRMAN DODD THANK YOU
BOTH VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP WANNA THANK ALL THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE POCKET
CASTRO ON BEHALF OF A A RP
REPRESENTING. THREE POINT FOUR
MILLION MEMBERS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
ON I JUST WANNA POINT OUT THAT.
ON BEHALF OF THESE CONSUMERS AND
THEY HAPPEN TO BE RATEPAYERS AND
HOMEOWNERS IN SOME CASES RENTERS.
WE ALSO HAVE TO REMEMBER ABOUT
THE LOW INCOME.
OLDER POPULATION THE EIGHTY YEAR
OLD THE NINE YEAR OLDS THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE LIVING MUCH
LONGER.
AND THEY WANT TO LIVE A LIFE OF
DIGNITY AND INDEPENDENCE.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I'VE.
I'VE HAVEN'T HEARD AND WE ARE
GONNA BE.
CLEARLY WATCHING IS ON THE
SECURITIZATION AND THE NEW
STANDARD FOR WEATHER TOOK THE
COSTA REASONABLE ON THE SIT ON
THE CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES.
WHERE THERE WERE YOU DETERMINED
THAT THE?
CPU OR THAT THE UTILITIES ARE
NOT NEXT.
WHAT WE REALLY WANT TO MAKE SURE
IS THAT REPAIRS ARE NOT?
THE BLANK CHECK THEY ARE NOT THE
BAILOUT.
AND THEY'RE NOT THE ONLY ONES
PAYING FOR ALL OF THE COST OF
RECOVERY.
SO WE REALLY JUST NEED TO REMIND
FOLKS THAT.
THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR HARD
WORK.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO ALL THE
DETAILS ON THIS AND I DO WANNA
Y. SOME OF MY COMMENTS WITH
AGNOSTIC HERNANDEZ REPRESENTING
TURN.
THANK YOU.
ALMOST THEIR PALETTE SHE ON
BEHALF OF BOTH PACHANGA IN
COLUSA.
AND I MAY BE THE ONLY ONE IN THE
ROOM THAT ACTUALLY REPRESENTS
THE LARGEST OF PRIVATE TRIBAL
FIRE DEPARTMENT WHICH IS
DEPLOYED EVERYONE OF YOUR
DISTRICTS FOR EVERY MAJOR FIRE.
BUT ALSO THE ONLY ONE THAT HAS
THE ONLY TRIBAL UTILITY IN THE
STATE.
SO HAVING SAID BOTH OF THOSE FOR
BOTH REASONS WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE WE HAVE A LOT RELIABILITY
AND HEALTH UTILITIES BECAUSE WE
WORK HAND IN HAND WITH THEM ON
BOTH OF THOSE ASPECTS SO THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN DODD
CHAIRMAN HOLDEN IN THE ENTIRE
COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS GLEN FUJI.
AND ON THE NATIONAL EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF A PAPA.
AND THAT TODAY WERE HAPPY TO SEE
THAT THE COMMITTEE HAS PUT FORTH
PRINCIPLES. TO ADDRESS THAT
ADDRESS THE ISSUES AFFECTING
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY IN THE
BUSINESS SECTOR.
WE WE BELIEVE AND FEEL THAT A
HEALTHY UTILITY IS CRITICAL FOR
THE JOB CREATION IN OUR STATE.
AND THAT RESPECTFULLY WE WE DO
URGE THAT --
YAK NOW IN WE ADOPT
COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTIONS.
THAT CAN PROTECT THE GROWING
BUSINESSES SO THANK YOU TODAY
FOR YOUR TIME.
GOOD AFTERNOON WAS TURNED
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE OUTSIDE
OF ON THE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA RELEASE --
FIRST AUTHORED BY ALIGNING MY
COMMENTS WITH --
OTHER CONSERVATION GROUPS A
SPOKESMAN FOR ME --
AN RTC DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE ON
CALIFORNIA AND PACIFIC FORCE
TRUSTS.
WHILE YOU'RE I THINK THE OUTLINE
ALSO REFERENCES OTHER PENDING
LEGISLATION WERE IN WHICH THE
DAY AT DIAMETER QUESTION IS
BEING CONSIDERED SO I DO THINK
IT IS RELEVANT TO THIS
DISCUSSION --
BUT BEYOND THAT CALIFORNIA
RELIEF --
WORKS ON URBAN FORESTRY ISSUES --
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WITH
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND SPECIFICALLY COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS WORKING IN CENTRAL
VALLEY --
FROM STOCKTON DOWN TO
BAKERSFIELD. ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE HAVE A CONCERN WITH IT
IS THAT THESE ARE ALL A LOT OF
THE SAME COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
HIT FIRST AND WORST BY A LOT OF
THE THE SMOKE PLUMES IN
PARTICULAR MATTER IMPACTS IN THE
VALLEY GIVEN --
WHENEVER OUR FORCED OPEN FLAMES --
JUST GIVEN THE NATURE OF THE
GEOLOGY OF CENTRAL VALLEY --
AND THE INABILITY FOR AIR TO TO
PUSH THAT THE BAD AYE AIR OUT OF
THE OUT OF THE VALLEY --
SO ONE OF THE THINGS THAT'S A
CONCERN GROWING CONCERN FOR US
IS --
RELATIVES OF THE BIOMASS
FACILITIES WHICH ALSO HAVE THEIR
OWN --
PARTICULATE MATTER AND AND
POLLUTION IMPACTS --
I WOULDN'T BE BRIEF --
DIDN'T AND FOR US WE WE WOULDN'T
REALLY APPRECIATE SAYING BEST
AVAILABLE CONTROL AND TECHNOLOGY
PARAMETERS BEING CROWNED THESE --
EXTENSIONS OF THE CONTRACTS ARE
VIOLENCE MASS BASILIDES --
WOULD REALLY APPRECIATE --
THAT BEING IN THE FINAL VERSION
OF THE COMMITTEE REPORT AND AND
LOOK FORWARD.
TO THE CONTINUE CONVERSATION
THANK YOU SPEAKER.
THANK YOU CO CHAIRING MEMBERS
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY PERSON IN
YONKERS NO DOOR PRIZE FOR THE
LAST SPEAKER.
OTHERS IF I MORE PEOPLE COMING
NEXT DON'T WORRY --
FIRST MIANI FOR CALIFORNIA LARGE
ENERGY CONSUMERS AND PART OF THE
RATE PAYER COALITION I THINK
YOU'VE HEARD.
LOUD AND CLEAR A LOT OF THOSE
CONCERNS AND AND I THINK WE
APPRECIATED THE COMMENTS FROM
THE DYESS YET WERE A BIT
SURPRISED AND DISAPPOINTED THAT.
THOSE RATE PAYER ACT CONCERNS
THAT WERE VOICED WHAT PART OF
THE DOCUMENT.
AND YOU KNOW BY WAY OF EXAMPLE
IN IN IN SOME OF THE ISSUES THE
SECURITIZATION FOR EXAMPLE
DOESN'T REALLY SHOW.
THAT THE INVESTORS ARE GOING TO
BE PAID FIRST AND I THINK THAT'S
AN IMPORTANT POINT THAT NEEDS TO
BE.
YOU KNOW HIGHLIGHTED AS AS WE GO
FORWARD --
IN THE DETAILS OF THIS WE'VE
HEARD A LOT OF THINGS ABOUT THE
STOCK PRICE BEING DRIVEN DOWN
AND IN CONCERN OVER EXISTING
CONTRACTS THE LAST TIME THE
STATE HAD.
A MAJOR ENERGY CRISIS ALL OF
THOSE CONTRACTS WERE ULTIMATELY
HONORED AND THEY THEY DIDN'T
FAIL SO I I'M NOT SURE THAT
THAT'S IT'S ALWAYS A CONCERN.
BUT I DON'T THINK IT'S SOMETHING
SHOULD BE THE FRONT OF THIS LIST --
AND LASTLY WE'VE PUT TOGETHER
SEVERAL PROPOSALS A OF THINGS
THAT WE THINK ARE ULTIMATELY
REASONABLE JUST AND REASONABLE
TO USE THE LANGUAGE.
PARLANCE OF THE OF ENERGY POLICY
IN CALIFORNIA AND WE FEEL LIKE
WE HAVE NOT REALLY BEEN HEARD UP
TO THIS POINT.
AS YOU MOVE FOR THE DETAILS THE
DETAILS MATTER.
I BELIEVE I SPEAK FOR EVERYONE
IN THE RATE PARA COALITION THAT
WE WOULD LOVE TO BE A RESOURCE --
FOR YOU IF YOU WILL FOR IN THAT
LANGUAGE AND TO THE EXTENT THAT
YOU WANT ANY OR ALL OF US TO BE
PART OF THAT DISCUSSION IN
DETAIL.
I I THINK WE WOULD ALL BE HAPPY
TO BE HERE OVER THE WEEKEND IF
YOU NEED US THANK YOU.
OKAY THAT --
LOOKS LIKE THAT CONCLUDES PUBLIC
COMMENT I DID --
IT RECOGNIZE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAYES.
I THINK YOU CHAIR AND YOU KNOW I
JUST WANTED TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THE COMMENTS MAYBE SHOULD HAVE
BEEN A LITTLE BIT MORE
AGGRESSIVE IN MY COMMENTS BEFORE --
FROM SOME OF MY GOOD FRIENDS AT
THAT WERE USING THE TERM BAILOUT
FROM WHAT'S IN FRONT.
I HAVEN'T HEARD ONE PERSON --
OF THIS CONFERENCE A COMMITTEE
IN FACT I HAVEN'T HEARD ONE
MEMBER THE LEGISLATURE WHO HAS
EVER SUGGESTED THAT WE WANT TO
BAIL OUT ANYONE --
WHAT WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO DO IS
TO PUT TOGETHER A PROPOSAL?
THAT MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE A
I'LL USE THAT I'M ARE GONNA GO A
BELLY UP.
AND THAT WE'RE GOING TO PROTECT
RATE PAYERS AT THE SAME TIME.
IT'S IT ONCE WE TOOK LIABILITY
REFORM OFF THE TABLE WHICH MANY
OF YOU WHO STE CAME TO SPEAK AT
TODAY TALKING ABOUT RATE PAYERS.
YOU THE SAME ONCE COMING TO
TAPPED TO US SAYING PLEASE I'D
YOU KNOW PLEASE DON'T HURT
PLEASE TAKE INVERSE CONDEMNATION
OFF.
OFF THE TABLE SOON AS YOU DO
THAT SOMEBODY'S GONNA END UP
HAVING TO PAY THERE IS VERY FEW
OF YOU THAT WERE LOOKED OVER
TRYING TO GET LIABILITY REFORM
DONE.
SO I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE OF
THAT THE SAME TIME WE DO HAVE A
SERIOUS PROBLEM ABOUT TWENTY
SEVENTEEN AND DEALING WITH --
WITH WITH WITH THE GENIE THAT
ISRAEL IS VERY REAL.
WE HAVE TO HAVE COURAGE UP HERE
TO BE ABLE TO MAKE.
AND IN REGARDS TO A BAILOUT I
THINK I'VE BEEN HERE FROM LOTS
OF FOLKS TALKING ABOUT THE
STRESS TEST SOMETHING LIKE WHAT
HAPPENED.
IN SAN BRUNO WERE LITERALLY
TAKING THE SHAREHOLDERS ARE
GONNA TARGET TAKE THE BIGGEST
BITE BEFORE THERE'S GONNA BE A
COST RECOVERY.
FROM RATEPAYERS I HAVEN'T HEARD
ANYBODY UP HERE TALK ABOUT THE
BAILING OUT THAT PETE YOU NEED
ANOTHER QUESTION ABOUT MOVING
FORWARD AND DOING ANY TYPE OF
COST RECOVERY.
ON A PROSPECTIVE BASIS WE STILL
HAVE TO WORK SOME OF THOSE SOME
OF THOSE DETAILS OUT BUT I JUST
WANT TO MAKE THE POINT I HAVEN'T
HEARD ANYBODY SAY.
THAT NOW WE'RE GONNA BELT BILL
ANYBODY OUT.
ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE I IN
REGARDS TO THAT THE HARDENING
THAT TO MAKE SURE THERE'S
MEASURES IN PLACE.
THAT ARE ALSO PROTECT RATEPAYERS
UP I THINK FOR ALL OF US WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT RATE PAYERS
ARE PROTECTED AND IT'S A BALLOTS.
I TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SOME A MEMBER DOLLARS SO
I'M REAL REAL QUICK I HAD MY
COLLEAGUE.
TALK ABOUT FIREWORKS SHOW YOU
THIS MAP HANGS MY OFFICE EVERY
DAY.
AND WHEN IT'S UPDATED.
WHICH HAPPENS ABOUT EVERY YEAR.
IT'S GETTING MORE RED.
THIS IS THE PROBLEM.
WE'VE GOT A FEW YEARS OF REALLY
CATASTROPHIC EVENTS THAT WE HAVE
EXPERIENCED IN THE PAST WHICH IS
WHAT PUT US IN THIS POSITION.
SO I WANT TO SAY TO THOSE WHO
ARE.
TALKING ABOUT THE SIZE OF A TREE
YOU CAN CUT AND THE VEGETATION.
I'VE BEEN HERE FOR SIX YEARS.
THE REASON YOU CAN CUT A TWENTY
SIX HISTORY WITH AN EXEMPTION IS
BECAUSE I AUTHORED THAT BILL.
AND IT WAS EIGHTEEN WHEN I CAME
HERE.
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT CUTTING
THIRTY SIX HAS TREES THAT WAS
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL THAT WAS
NOT.
MISTER WOOD IN MINE.
SO I WILL ASSURE YOU THAT WE
WILL BE DOING PRUDENT AND THE M.
WHEREVER SHE WHERE THE QUADRATIC
ME SO WE CAN GET IN THE WEEDS WE
REALLY WANT TO START TALKING
ABOUT.
GOOD FORESTRY AND I KNOW YOU
DON'T WANT TO GO THERE BECAUSE I
DON'T EITHER.
BUT I WILL SAY ASSURE YOU THAT I
HAVE A REPUTATION OF DOING THE
RIGHT THING WHEN IT COMES TO
BEING ON THE GROUND AND TAKING
CARE OF OUR ENVIRONMENT.
AND MAKING IT FIRE RESILIENT
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO.
IN AND I SAID EARLIER IN THE
FOREST.
WE ARE GONNA DO WE HAVE TOO MANY
TREES AND SOME OF THOSE TREES.
A LITTLE BIT BIGGER AND ACTUALLY
THOSE ONES A LITTLE BIT BIGGER
HAVE VALUE AND HELPS US PAY ITS
WAY OUT.
SO WE'LL BE DOING THAT DYNAMIC
BALANCE AT THE AT THE RIGHT WAY.
AND IT WILL BE ALL UP FRONT AND
WILL NOT BE A THIRTY SIX HISTORY
AND THE ACTUAL SIZE OF TREES PER
ACRE WILL GO UP BECAUSE WE'RE
TAKE ON THE LITTLE ONES OUT
THANK YOU.
I I JUST LIKE.
TO THERE'S LOT OF IMPORTANT
THINGS HAVE BEEN SAID --
AND THE COMMENTS FROM THE PUBLIC
IS ALWAYS APPRECIATED I JUST
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT.
THAT HOWEVER THIS ULTIMATELY
PLAYS OUT IT WILL BE SOME TYPE
OF RECOMMENDATION THAT WILL
HAPPEN THIS YEAR.
THE OTHER PART I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE.
IS THAT BEFORE THIS.
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE STARTED
MEETING.
IN THE SUMMER.
OF JULY WE STARTED HEARING THAT
SOMEHOW.
WE'RE GOING TO BE MAKING
DECISIONS OUT OF THE PUBLIC'S
EYE OF THE VIEW AND MAYBE NOT
TAKING EVERYONE'S.
AKA POINTS INTO CONSIDERATION I
LIKE TO THINK I'VE HEARD AT
LEAST A FEW PEOPLE SAY TODAY
THAT.
THAT'S NOT THE CASE THIS HAS
BEEN A TRANCE PARENT PROCESS.
AND WE TRIED TO COVERS MANY
ELEMENTS OF WHAT WAS IMPORTANT
TO TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION.
AND NOW WE ARE.
LITERALLY IN THE FOURTH QUARTER
AND I THINK IT'S CLEAR THAT.
AS WE'VE ALL SAID.
OF THE DETAILS ARE YET TO BE
HASHED OUT.
A BUT I THINK YOU DO LEAST
CONCEDE THE THE DIRECTION THAT
WE'RE GOING TO AND AND IT'S AN
IMPORTANT ERECTION AND I THINK
THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE.
TO ARE GOING TO BE ABLE TO BE AS
RESPONSIVE AS WE HAVE BEEN TO
BECAUSE WE CAN BE TO ALL THE
DIFFERENT ELEMENTS THAT
REPRESENTED SO.
I JUST WANT TO THANK EVERYONE
FOR BEING HERE AND FOR YOU ALL
PARTICIPATING BECAUSE YOUR HELP
SAVE.
OUR THINKING AND HOPEFULLY THAT
WILL BE REFLECTED IN THE REPORT.
OKAY --
GIVEN THE OUTLINE WHICH HAS BEEN
DEVELOPED BASED ON OUR PRIOR
HEARINGS AND INPUT I THE
PRODUCTIVE DISCUSSION HERE TODAY.
I THINK WE HAVE A GOOD DIRECTION
TO STAFF TING.
THE CONFERENCE REPORT.
I BELIEVE THAT REPORT WILL
REFLECT A HOLISTIC APPROACH THAT
WILL HELP STOP FIRES FROM
SPARKING IN SPREADING
UNCONTROLLABLY.
SAY BEING COMMUNITIES OF
TAXPAYER SIGNIFICANT COSTS IN
AVOID AND INVOICE BEING --
DISASTERS AND PROTECT UTILITY
RAPIERS FROM BEARING AND DO
COSTS.
WE HEAR THE PROPOSED CONFERENCE
REPORT WE WILL HEAR THE PROPOSED
CONFERENCE REPORT WHEN WE CAN BE
NEXT WEEK.
AGAIN I'D LIKE TO THANK MY CO
CHAIR ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN AND
HIS STAFF IN OUR FELLOW
CONFEREES AND STAFF --
OF IT FOR EVERYONE --
WHOSE PROVIDED --
ALSO ALL OF YOU THEY'RE PRETTY
PROVIDED PUBLIC COMMENT TODAY
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH THIS
MEETINGS ADJOURNMENT